Now I can do anything. I like my friends. I like my podcast. I like my Jason. I like my First of all, though, I would just like to say really fast. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Oh, we'll have to be there, Willard. Happy birthday to you. Oh, my gosh. at birthday to you. Have birthday to you. Oh, we'll have a birthday. Birthday. Well, aren't that. Oh my gosh. Happy birthday to you. And it's on May the 4th.
现在我什么都能做。我喜欢我的朋友。我喜欢我的播客。我喜欢我的杰森。我喜欢我的……不过首先，我只想快点说一句。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。哦，我们得去那儿，威勒德。祝你生日快乐。哦，天哪。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。哦，我们要过生日。生日。嗯，不是那个。哦，天哪。祝你生日快乐。而且正好在5月4日。
Be with you. No, no, this is, which is one of my biggest regrets that somebody came up with that. I love it. You can't even. It's first time for me. No, because it just, it's just completely, you know, taking my birthday hostage forever. Not for me. It's, you're lucky you're not born not born on the, on 420, right?
愿原力与你同在。不，不，这是……这是我最大的遗憾之一，居然有人想出了这个。我太喜欢了。你简直……这对我来说还是第一次。不，因为这完全……你知道的，把我的生日永远扣为人质了。对我来说可不是。真幸运，你没有出生在……没有出生在4月20日，对吧？
Isn't that the, with all the kids like to smoke their weed on the 420? Huh? 20. Hey man, I've been, I've been looking for ways for you to sound older. Yeah. And I think we just found it, you know,
难道那不是……所有的孩子都喜欢在4月20日抽大麻的日子吗？啊？20。嘿，老兄，我一直在……我一直在找办法让你听起来老一点。对。而我想我们刚刚找到了，你知道的，
how about this? Does this sound? Oh, no. Oh, no. I'm, how about this? It's also, but, but, but Jason, for you and me, it's also more importantly, it's Cinco de Quatro. Cinco de Quatro, very big deal. People that know about arrested. And the rest of the development can in Sean.
这个怎么样？听起来像吗？哦，不。哦，不。我……这个怎么样？而且，但是，但是，杰森，对你我而言，更重要的是，这也是五月四日节。五月四日节，这可是个大日子。看过《发展受阻》的人都知道。
So thank you. Sean, thank you for following the show. Speaking of Sean, let's take a moment to celebrate Sean's Tony Award nomination. I don't wave it away. It's a big deal. Yeah. Thank you. And very well deserved. Good Lord. That show. Good. Again, just to repeat, anybody going through the Tri-State area, stop in New York City. It's a fun town. And there's a great show. What's the theater? What's the theater? Good night Oscar at the Bolasco Theater. The Bolasco.
所以谢谢你。肖恩，谢谢你收听节目。说到肖恩，让我们花点时间庆祝一下肖恩获得托尼奖提名。别把它挥手不当回事。这可是件大事。对。谢谢。而且实至名归。天哪。那场演出。太棒了。再说一次，任何路过三州地区的人，都在纽约市停留一下。这是个有趣的城市。而且有一场精彩的演出。剧院叫什么名字？剧院叫什么名字？贝拉斯科剧院的《晚安，奥斯卡》。贝拉斯科。
Yeah, some people call it Tabasco, but that's just so they can remember it. Jason, do you know what the Tony Awards are short for? Do you know what the actual name of the award is? Anthony's. Close, no. Sean, you know, right? Antoinette.
对，有些人叫它塔巴斯科（Tabasco），但那只是为了好记。杰森，你知道托尼奖是哪个词的简称吗？你知道这个奖项的全名是什么吗？安东尼。差不多，不对。肖恩，你知道的，对吧？安托瓦内特。
Antoinette Perry Award. Really? Yeah. God, you know, listen, are you shocked as me at how smart Will every once in a while is, I am. He'd also be shocked to know these actually 67 today. He does have, you do have like an endless well of just knowledge and stuff. I got a lot of time. I got a lot of time on my hands. Literally. Jason, I said to Jason yesterday, I said, hey, do you want to read this thing that I just wrote? And he said, please don't.
安托瓦内特·佩里奖。真的吗？对。天哪，你知道的，听着，你有没有像我一样惊讶于威尔偶尔表现得这么聪明？我是。你也一定会大吃一惊，他其实今天67岁了。他确实……你确实拥有取之不尽的知识和各种东西。我有的是时间。我有很多空闲时间。真的。杰森，我昨天对杰森说，我说，嘿，你想读一下我刚写的东西吗？他说，请别。
Please don't. No, he said, he said, I'm going to send you that script. I said, please don't. He says, what do you mean? I go, I don't, I don't, I don't even read my own texts. Yeah. He's like, well, thank you for your honesty. I just thought, you know, it's just a fun script.
请别。不，他说，他说，我要把那个剧本发给你。我说，请别。他说，你什么意思？我说，我……我连我自己的短信都不读。对。他当时说，好吧，谢谢你的诚实。我只是觉得，你知道的，这只是个有趣的剧本。
I said, there's nothing fun about reading. I know. Yeah, my parents really screwed me. I just thought, you know, it's just a fun script. I said, there's nothing fun about reading. Did say that. Yeah, my parents really screwed me. Now, I'm watching Sean there, it's his eye. Sean, Sean just had a, we call it, ocular surgery, laser surgery. We don't call it that, but he had a, I can't read, I'm not supposed to read.
我说，阅读一点都不有趣。我懂。对，我父母真的把我坑惨了。我只是觉得，你知道的，这只是个有趣的剧本。我说，阅读一点都不有趣。确实说过。对，我父母真的把我坑惨了。现在，我看着肖恩那边，是他的眼睛。肖恩……肖恩刚刚做了一个……我们叫它眼科手术，激光手术。我们不这么叫，但他做了一个……我看不见，我不应该阅读。
He's not supposed to read. And I said, Sean said, Sean turned to the doctor, said, you can't read. And Sean said, boy, do I have some good news for you. He does have a detached ret. So Sean's got a partially detached ret now Jason got a detached personality. So we have hey, hey, oh, um, but, but, uh, but Sean, you're still doing seven shows this week after laser surge. Yeah.
他不应该阅读。然后我说，肖恩说……肖恩转向医生说，你不能阅读。然后肖恩说，天哪，我可有个好消息要告诉你。他的视网膜确实脱落了……所以肖恩现在部分视网膜脱落了，而杰森有人格分裂。所以我们有……嘿，嘿，哦……但是，但是，但是，肖恩，做完激光手术这周你居然还要演七场秀？对。
I'm not supposed to read or dart my eye around a lot. And that was the direction from the director, from the doctor said, don't dart your eyes. Wait, it was his note from the director and the doctor. No, and I said to both of you guys, I'm slowly turning into my mother. I'm going to lose my eye. I mean, it's list you've been a knock on wood. No, you mom lost her eye from cancer, you said not from a detached retina. She was two years old.
我不应该阅读，也不能频繁转动眼球。这是导演……这是医生的叮嘱，说不要转动眼球。等等，这是导演和医生的叮嘱。不，我对你们俩说，我正在慢慢变成我妈。我要瞎了。我是说……谢天谢地。不，你妈妈是因为癌症失明的，你说的不是视网膜脱落。她当时才两岁。
Yeah, she was two years old. She was two years old when she lost her eye. Oh my god. Yeah, we're still looking for it. So wait, and so I went in and I get vaso vagals. Do you guys get that? Sure. Hey, man, we're trying to keep it clean over here, dude.
对，她当时两岁。她失明的时候才两岁。哦，天哪。对，我们还在找呢。所以等等，然后我去了，我得了血管迷走神经性昏厥。你们得过这个吗？当然。嘿，老兄，我们想在这里保持纯洁，老兄。
What are you? It's when you get nauseous and faint from like, you know, needles or poking at your eyeballs. That's happening to me once. Oh, I get it all the time. That's what I mean once. So you just go out if you get nervous about it. I am like, I have to lay down. I need a fan. I need coolness. I'm going to throw up. I am like, I have to lay down. I need a fan.
你是什么？就是当你看到针头或者有人戳你的眼球时，就会恶心和晕厥。我经历过一次。哦，我经常这样。这就是我说的“一次”的意思。所以只要你对此感到紧张，你就会直接晕过去。我简直……我得躺下。我需要风扇。我需要凉爽。我要吐了。我简直……我得躺下。我需要风扇。
I need coolness. I'm going to throw up. I'm going to shoot. We all feel better with a fan around. Let's be honest. Oh, what about doing a show? Do you ever feel it coming on just with nerves for the show? No, no, that's different.
我需要凉爽。我要吐了。我要……说实话，有风扇在身边，我们都会感觉好点。哦，那演出呢？光是为演出紧张，你就会有这种感觉吗？不，不，那不一样。
This is all doctor health related stuff. Like if I'm in, I passed out getting contact lenses once. I passed out like, I tried like 10 years ago to get Botox and I passed out. But you're trying to get it fairness. You were trying to get it directly from the cow, right? And it's like, Sean, what I've been amazing is if you passed out going in for Botox and you fell and cut
这全是医生的健康相关问题。就像如果我在……我曾经因为戴隐形眼镜而晕倒过。大约10年前，我尝试过去打肉毒杆菌，结果我晕倒了。但为了公平起见，你是想试着。你是想直接从母牛身上提取，对吧？就像是……肖恩，如果你去打肉毒杆菌时晕倒了，然后摔倒割伤了
yourself and then you had to get stitches and then you passed out while trying to get the stitches from the passing of getting. I do, I get it so bad, you guys don't get that. No man. Not just occurred to me, we're doing a full talk show. We do a talk show and right now we're doing the Regis and Kathy Lee pattern beforehand, right? What are you talking about? Well, I used to watch that show and I'm like, how do they come up with this stuff?
自己，然后你得去缝针，结果在缝针时因为刚才晕倒引起的晕倒又晕倒了，那可就太神奇了。我真的……我反应太严重了，你们不会这样的。没有吧，老兄。我突然想到，我们正在做一个完整的脱口秀。我们做了一个脱口秀，而现在我们在进行事前采访的里吉斯和凯茜·李模式，对吧？你在说什么？好吧，我以前看那个节目时就在想，他们怎么能想出这些东西？
Regis just comes in with this coffee, talks about his weekend, and it covers as full national entertainment for 20 minutes. I could talk about 9,000 things for an hour. I don't think people are interested, right? I mean, what are we, what are we doing? Jason, Jason's gonna say is he's not interested in your life. I'm not interested in myself. He's not interested in himself. Let's get to the stage. We are going to get, we are going to get somebody interesting, but I do want to say Jason was so grumpy yesterday. Oh my god. I was impressed. Jason and I played golf the last three days. And then yesterday, we, none of us played particularly well.
里吉斯拿着咖啡走进来，谈论他的周末，然后这就能当成20分钟的全国完整娱乐内容。我可以花一个小时谈论9000件事。我觉得大家可能不感兴趣，对吧？我是说，我们……我们在干什么？杰森，杰森会说他对你的生活不感兴趣。我对我自己都不感兴趣。他对自己的生活也不感兴趣。我们进入正题吧。我们会……我们会请来一些有趣的人，但我确实想说，杰森昨天脾气太暴躁了。哦，天哪。我印象深刻。杰森和我过去三天都在打高尔夫。然后昨天我们……我们谁也没打得特别好。
Tuesday, we got to play with football great legend, Gareth Bale, who is just an absolute for the Americans. Yeah. I mean, just an absolute. But you had to be like, freaking this guy's a real, I was, I was, God, he's unreal, right? Yeah, you're a little nervous. It was like your plan was Charlie's Theron. I was, yeah, hey man.
周二，我们得以和伟大的足球传奇人物加雷斯·贝尔一起打球，对美国人来说，他绝对是个……对。我是说，绝对是个……但你一定觉得，天哪，这家伙太真实了。我是……我是，天哪，他太不可思议了，对吧？对，你有点紧张。就像你的计划是查理兹·塞隆一样。我当时……对，嘿，老兄。
Just. How did it come about you guys just play golf with all these people? Right. They just randomly show up. We host a talk show, bro. Yeah. I know, but I'm just saying like, how do you organize that? Well, we met this guy up at some to let golf tournament.
只是。你们怎么会突然和所有这些人一起打高尔夫的？对啊。他们就随机出现吗？我们主持脱口秀，老兄。对。我知道，我的意思是，你们是怎么安排的？嗯，我们在某个慈善高尔夫锦标赛上遇到了这个人。
And then that's what happens. Hey, let's play golf. And then we swap numbers. Yeah, he's a good guy. And then that's what happens. Hey, let's play golf. And then we saw numbers. Yeah, he's a good guy. We do. We swap numbers. We go like, Hey, man, we want to play golf with you, Gareth Bailey. So I'm sure at least wanted to play golf.
然后事情就这么发生了。嘿，我们去打高尔夫吧。然后我们交换了号码。对，他是个好人。然后事情就这么发生了。嘿，我们去打高尔夫吧。然后我们交换了号码。对，他是个好人。我们确实换了。我们说，嘿，老兄，我们想和你打高尔夫，加雷斯·贝尔。所以我想至少想打高尔夫。
You would like to play. I'm not answering this. Listen, I'm just pleating. Now I'm now pleading the fifth. Hey, anyway, I was I was a real. So he was a grump. He he spat out of the parking lot into the point that 30 seconds after he left out to come and go, Hey, man, are you okay? Why? Why? He did call because I was getting out of the parking lot into the point that 30 seconds after he left out to come and go, he meant, are you okay?
你想打。我不回答这个。听着，我只是在求饶。现在我……我现在要保持沉默。嘿，不管怎样，我真是个……所以他是个脾气暴躁的人。他气冲冲地离开停车场，以至于他离开30秒后又折回来，说：“嘿，老兄，你没事吧？”为什么？他确实折回来了，因为我当时正开着车离开停车场，以至于他离开30秒后又折回来，说：“嘿，老兄，你没事吧？”
Why? He did call because I was getting out of the parking lot. I was like, oh, no, maybe I've pissed him off because I don't really say goodbye to anybody. I just had to get out of there before I embarrass myself by like going into some sort of, I played a bad golf round rage. I can't find it. I was proud. It was what happened.
为什么？他确实折回来了，因为我当时正开着车离开停车场。我在想，哦，不，也许我惹毛他了，因为我其实没有跟任何人道别。我只是必须在那儿之前离开，以免自己因为某种“我打了一场糟糕的高尔夫球”的狂怒而丢脸。我找不到了。我很自豪。事情就是这样的。
I was putting my stuff in the back of my car and his window was open. And then as he's putting it up and his car is now in drive, he looks over. I'm not exaggerating. He goes like this. I will zip up the window and kill that. And I was like, fuck you. I'll be because you played a bad game. Yeah, I just I play too much to play that badly.
我当时在把东西放进车后备箱，他的车窗是开着的。然后当他把车窗升上去、车子已经挂上前进挡时，他转过头来。我没有夸张。他做了个这个手势。我摇起车窗，恨恨地想。当时我就想，去你的。我之所以会这样，是因为你打得很烂。对，我……我打得太多了，不应该打得这么烂。
And I just need to be more disciplined and I need to actually really, if I'm gonna, if I'm gonna be upset about not playing well, I need to have a reason to play in other words. I need to start like really training or something. Jay, Jay, I thought about it. I thought about this. And this is not a joke.
我只需要更有纪律性，而且我真的需要……如果我要……如果我要为自己打得不好而感到沮丧的话，我需要有一个去打球的理由，换句话说。我需要开始真正地训练什么的。杰，杰，我想过了。我考虑过这个。这不是开玩笑。
We joke about this a lot. We're gonna get to your guess. I feel badly for them, but I just wanna say this, you yesterday, and he does this a lot, did this last two days. No. We're going to, it was that, but I just want to say this. You yesterday, and he does this a lot, did this last two days. We're going to, it was like, hey,
我们经常拿这个开玩笑。我们要聊你的嘉宾了。我替他们感到难过，但我只是想说这个，你昨天——他经常这样，这两天也这样。不。我们要去……就是那个，但我只是想说这个。你昨天——他经常这样，这两天也这样。我们要去……就像是，嘿，
do you want a little bit of food? They got a little snack shack, and I get like a little chicken salad. Maybe you think, and Jason's last two days goes, yeah, just give me a cup of sliced apples. That's all he had. And I'm like, he's starving to death. That's what's going on.
你想吃点东西吗？他们有个小食杂店，我拿了一点鸡肉沙拉。也许你觉得，而杰森这两天都说，好吧，就给我一杯切好的苹果。他就吃了这个。然后我想，他饿得快死了。事情就是这样。
He's literally built can't shake these five or ten pounds. Dude Jason, what I told Jason, if he loses ten pounds, I'm taking him to the fucking hospital. Yeah, you don't need to lose any more weight, Jason. Sean, he ate a cup of sliced apples. That's it. I'm like, that's not enough when you want to. With a cup of nuts on top of those. Don't you get tired during the day from not eating? Yes. I can't wait. I can't wait. You know what I did? Well, there's here's the sickness. I came home. I saw Amanda in the kitchen. She's like, hi, what's wrong? I go, nothing. I'm a disaster.
他 literalmente 怎么也甩不掉这五到十磅的赘肉。老兄，杰森，我对杰森说过，如果他瘦了十磅，我就把他送进医院。对，你不需要再减肥了，杰森。肖恩，他吃了一杯切好的苹果。就这样。我就觉得，当你想要……上面还撒了一把坚果。你不会因为不吃东西而在白天感到疲倦吗？会。我等不及了。我等不及了。你知道我做了什么吗？好吧，这里有个毛病。我回到家，看到阿曼达在厨房。她问，嗨，怎么了？我说，没事。我简直一团糟。
I'm embarrassed because I'm in a bad mood because of golf. She goes, really? I go, yeah, she goes, we want to talk about it. I said, you don't want any part of me. I'm going to the gym. So I put on my gym clothes and I went and I ran on the elliptical for an hour and then sweated out in the hot box for an hour. So, two hours, I just had to get into a deep sweat to get all the rage out of me. By the way, what you don't hear in there is any nutrition going in. I know. That's what I'm saying.
我很尴尬，因为我打高尔夫打得心情不好。她说，真的吗？我说，对。她她说，我们要聊聊吗？我说，你可不想沾包。我要去健身房。所以我换上健身服，去椭圆机上跑了一个小时，然后在高温房里蒸了一个小时的汗。所以，整整两个小时，我必须出透汗，把身上的怒气全排出来。顺便说一句，你在那里听不到的是有任何营养摄入。我知道。这就是我想说的。
His mood and blood sugar is plummeting. That's what your body is like screaming at you for backing you up. Both of you to see. There we go. I don't know what the hell you're talking about. Let's get to your guest, huh? Yeah, unless you got some other right. Yes. No, I do. I want to get to the great yet, but did want to want to remind anybody if you're interested in what you're hearing, we have actual actual pictures of us doing this too. Moving pictures there on max, smart
他的情绪和血糖在直线下降。这就是你的身体在冲你尖叫，在警告你。你们两个看着办吧。好吧。我不知道你在胡说八道些什么。我们来聊聊你的嘉宾吧，哈？对，除非你还有别的……没错。不，我有。我想去请那位伟大的嘉宾，但确实想……想提醒大家，如果你对你听到的内容感兴趣，我们也有我们实际做这个的真实画面。动态影像都在Max上，智能
list on the road, the doc that that me,, that, that me, Will and Sean are enjoying, but we're a little biased, we're in it. But if you're interested, it's on Max there, our, our little docu series called on the, yeah. It, you know, May 23rd on Max was the, the day that that's right. Yeah, and they all came out at the same, and you can get all six episodes at the same time. Yeah, if you're a danger, binge away. Yeah, all right, all right, all right. My guest, fellas, listeners, do you like funny people? Sure do.
榜单在路上，我和威廉、肖恩都很享受这部纪录片，虽然我们有点偏心，因为我们就在里面。但如果你感兴趣，它就在Max上，我们的……我们的小型纪录片系列叫《On the……》。对。它，你知道的，5月23日在Max上线，就是那个……没错。对，它们都是同时发布的，你可以一次性看完所有六集。对，如果你是个危险人物，那就开启狂看模式吧。对，好，好，好。我的嘉宾，伙计们，听众们，你们喜欢有趣的人吗？当然喜欢。
Talented people, kind people. What if you managed to pack that into one woman? Add two scoops of charm and a cup of conversation skills and what do you get? You get her next guest gang. She's an American actress starring in a new show, which I'm very lucky enough to be a producer on. She's a new mom, an ex-tennis player,
有才华的人，善良的人。如果你能把这些全部打包在一个女人身上呢？再加上两勺魅力和一杯交谈技巧，你会得到什么？各位，你们会迎来接下来的嘉宾。她是一位美国女演员，主演了一部新剧，我很幸运能担任该剧的制片人。她是一位新手妈妈，前网球运动员，
and horseback writer. She's a native California and a proud Sagittarius and the daughter of Lane and Gary. Please welcome pure sunlight wrapped in skin, Miss Kaylee Quokko. Oh, good. Look at her go. Look at her Quokko. Have you ever been called Sunshine wrapped in skin? I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited.
也是马术骑手。她是地道的加利福尼亚人，一个骄傲的射手座，也是莱恩和加里的女儿。请欢迎被阳光包裹的纯粹光芒，凯莉·库柯小姐。哦，太棒了。看她走过来。看看我们的库柯。你有没有被人叫做“被皮肤包裹的阳光”？我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。
I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited.
我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。
I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. Yeah, no, Sean, at your disorder, which I think I have the fainting disorder with needles. That's really? Yes. Yes. Well, then that gets me into my first question. During my deep research, because I'm a crack journalist, you had a horse riding accident where you almost lost your leg. I'm not exposing anything big here. This was already out.
我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。对，不，肖恩，在你的那个毛病上——我觉得我也有对针头的晕厥症。真的吗？是的。好吧，那就把我引入了我的第一个问题。在我深入的研究中，因为我是一个优秀的记者，你曾有过一次差点失去一条腿的骑马事故。我这可不是在爆什么大料。这早就公开了。
Oh, yeah. How did you deal with that? You're never exposing anything big. So, hey, Will, that sounds like a sexual insult. Now I'm going to let you correct that for a second because it really sounded like I just wanted to say hi, Kayleigh. How are you? I feel like we've only met once before at something that you were hosting. You were backstage and you were like in a complete blackout. It seemed like not, what? No, you had to do a bunch of stuff.
哦，是的。你是怎么处理这件事的？你从来没爆过什么大料。所以，嘿，威廉，听起来像是个性骚扰。现在我要让你纠正一下，因为听起来真的……我只是想打个招呼，凯莉。你好吗？我觉得我们以前只在某个你主持的活动上见过一次。你在后台，而且好像完全断片了。看起来不像，什么？不，你当时得做一堆事情。
She's probably focused. She's professional. I've never been focused in my life. That is shocking. But it's so I'm so glad to be here. I'm nervous. You guys is like one of the best podcasts in my sister. It's her favorite one.
她可能很专注。她很专业。我这辈子就没专注过。这太令人震惊了。但我真的很高兴来到这里。我很紧张。你们的节目就像是我姐姐最喜欢的播客之一。这是她最喜欢的。
And she's like, if you mess this up, there's nothing to mess up. There's nothing to mess up. This is the best it gets. We're not going to say it a word in Edgewise. Don't worry about it. Jason's got a big question for you. So settle in and I hope you pack the lunch. So, so, so you're riding a horse. You ride the horse. You're jumping over gates and going around barrels and whatever the fuck you do. And then you get, and then, and then you,
然后她说，如果你把这搞砸了……没什么好搞砸的。没什么好搞砸的。这就是最好的状态。我们一句话也插不上。别担心。杰森有个大问题要问你。所以坐好吧，我希望你带了午餐。所以，所以……你在骑马。你骑着马。你跳过栅栏，绕着木桶跑，或者随便你妈的在干什么。然后你被……然后，然后你……
then the horse falls or you fall. The horse falls on you. Lands on the leg is stuck on the leg. Broke, broken the leg. Did you on the leg, broke, broken the leg. Did you ask the horse to get off to the horse, get off immediately? Wait, how long ago was this? This was a while ago. This was, let's see, it was beginning a big bang and we've been probably, I don't know, 12 or 13 years ago. Oh my God, okay, now.
然后马摔倒了或者你摔倒了。马压在你身上。压在腿上，卡在腿上。骨折了，腿骨折了。你当时让马从腿上下来了吗？马立刻下来了吗？等等，这是多久以前的事了？这有一段时间了。这是……让我想想，那是《生活大爆炸》刚开始的时候，大概……我不知道，12或13年前吧。哦，天哪，好吧，现在。
So guys, she almost lost her leg. I once asked her, I once asked her horse to's to get off during a big bag. I see. I'm gonna show it well. So, it's the birthday he's on fire. You really almost lost your leg on this and I was. Well, yeah, no, it was a bad accent. It was a very bad accent. And, yeah, he, I had fallen, the fall didn't hurt me.
所以伙计们，她差点失去了一条腿。我曾经要求她的马……在《生活大爆炸》期间下来。我懂。我会给威廉看看的。所以，今天是他的生日，他状态正火。你真的差点在这上面失去一条腿，当时我……好吧，对，不，这是一场严重的事故。这是一场非常严重的事故。而且，是的，他……我摔了，摔的那一下并没有弄伤我。
He ended up stepping on me. And I remember, I know. And the crazy part is. Sean just faded. Win it. You get that. Sean's down. And he can't do it.
他最后踩到了我。我记得，我知道。最疯狂的是，肖恩直接虚脱了。赢了。你懂的。肖恩倒下了。而他做不到。
So he's screwed. He looks to get the paddles. So he's dead. Don't fade. Kaley, how old were you when this happened? I was, oh my god, it can't be enough. Early 20s? It was probably 22.
所以他完蛋了。他去找除颤仪。所以他死了。别虚脱。凯莉，这事发生时你多大？我，哦天哪，肯定没多久。20岁出头？大概22岁吧。
Yeah. Wow. Oh, yeah. Wow. So, so now, but you had to sign something before surgery that gives a doctor permission that once they get in there and they see that maybe we might not be able to save the leg that you won't sue them if you wake up without the leg. Yes. It was a reaction of emergency. It was really serious.
是啊。哇。哦，对。哇。所以，所以现在，你在手术前必须签署一份文件，授权医生：一旦他们进去发现可能保不住你的腿时，你不会因为醒来后少了一条腿而起诉他们。是的。这是紧急情况下的反应。这真的很严重。
It was serious. So I had to go under. I'd assigned something. Yes, exactly right. And luckily I came out and I was, so but wait, wait, talk to, do you remember, you probably don't remember because you were so under anesthesia,
这很严重。所以我得进行全麻。我签了文件。是的，完全没错。幸运的是我醒来后，我，等等，等等，你还记得吗，你可能不记得了，因为你麻醉得太厉害了，
but when you first woke up, was your first look down to see if the leg was still there? You remember that? Yes, totally. Oh yeah, no, I have a very, yeah. How, what are we talking about? We're talking about it separated from your body, like what? I had a compound fracture.
但当你刚醒来时，你第一眼是往下看腿还在不在吗？你还记得吗？是的，完全记得。哦对，不，我有很深的，对。等等，我们在说什么？我们在讨论它和你的身体分离，就像什么？我粉碎性骨折了。
So for those who don't know it's the bone that comes out of your leg yeah wait wait wait which bone oh that's what I've got my tibia fibula so it's near my ankle and my knee my bones always coming out well this is what they all know is okay it's caught with his bone yeah no. So you had to call it. That's what it's called. Okay. Sorry. I'm going to have to update my first bit taking 100. I'm going to have to update my dating profile. That's what it's called. Wait. I don't know if it works.
所以对于不知道的人来说，就是骨头从腿里戳出来了，对，等等，等等，哪根骨头？哦，我有胫骨和腓骨，所以是在我的脚踝和膝盖附近，我的骨头总是戳出来。好吧，大家都知道，好吧，这是卡在骨头里的，对，不。所以你得叫它。这就是它的名字。好吧。对不起。我得更新我的初次约会自我介绍。这就是它的名字。等等。我不知道这管不管用。
You're creating a compound fracture. Yeah. Okay, so wait. Don't come in here. I've got a compound fracture. So wait. Yeah, okay, so wait don't come in here. I've got a cup of So your bone is sticking out of your the top part of your thigh or your bottom No, no, no, no, no, ankle ankle knee. Okay, so there was two. Yeah, and so it just was a horrible horrible horrible break And I had been and you say it didn't hurt? No, it, oh no, it did hurt.
你造成了粉碎性骨折。对。好吧，等等。别进来。我粉碎性骨折了。所以等等。对，好吧，等等，别进来。我有杯子，所以你的骨头从你的大腿上部还是下部戳出来了？不，不，不，不，不，脚踝，脚踝，膝盖。好吧，所以有两个。对，所以这是一个非常非常非常可怕的骨折。我一直，你说不痛？不，它，哦不，确实很痛。
Oh my God, I was gonna say, when I fell, the fall didn't break my, my fall was in the big deal. He stepped on me and I remember a clear as day, because it takes a second when something is up and I was like, did I just fall on a whole thing of leaves? Cause I heard all the cracking. The croncin'. Yeah, so I was like, are there leaves? And it took me like five or 10 seconds
哦天哪，我本来想说，当我摔倒时，摔倒并没有弄断我的，我摔倒其实没什么大不了的。他踩到了我，我记得清清楚楚，因为当事情发生时需要缓一缓，当时我想，我是不是摔在一堆树叶上了？因为我听到了一片碎裂的声音。嘎吱嘎吱的声音。对，所以我当时想，是有树叶吗？我花了大概五到十秒钟才
to actually realize it wasn't just 400 leaves, it was my bones. Yeah. So what do you have pins and rods in there? No, I have, you got to do. Do you set off metal detectors? No, I always thought I would, but it never happened. No, no.
真正意识到那不是400片树叶，而是我的骨头。对。那你里面有钢钉和钢板吗？不，我有，你得做。你会触发金属探测器吗？不，我一直以为我会，但从来没有发生过。不，不。
Oh my god, what was the recovery like for that? Like just, you know what's crazy? So I was shooting Big Bang. It was on a Friday after work. And so I was supposed to go to work on Monday. They put you behind the bar, right? They gave you like a bar job. Oh my, yes. I'm like, I have to call Chuck Laurie
哦天哪，那段恢复期是怎样的？就像，你知道最疯狂的是什么吗？当时我正在拍《生活大爆炸》。那是周五下班后。所以周一我本该去上班的。他们让你在酒吧工作，对吧？他们给你安排了一个酒吧的工作。哦天哪，是的。我当时想，我得给查克·洛尔打电话，
and tell him right now that I- The great Chuck Laurie. Just, yes, the great Chuck Laurie, but you don't want to make that call. And so they literally didn't think I would like walk for three months. They thought I would not walk for three months. I was walking in a week with a boot. I was back to work in two weeks. It was like miraculous.
现在就告诉他我——伟大的查克·洛尔。就是，对，伟大的查克·洛尔，但你根本不想打这通电话。所以他们根本没想到我三个月内能走路。他们以为我三个月都不能走路。我一周内就穿着保护靴走路了。两周后我就回去工作了。简直就像奇迹一样。
Wow. God. Yeah. I mean, I, you know, they always say the worst. And then I, I ended up being okay, but like it, they were very. So wait, you, but you still, it's now, because listen to the story, I'm on pins and needles. So you actually have pins in there for real? Yes, I do. They didn't take those out. They're not planning on taking those out. No, I went back in years later and I was like,
哇。天哪。对，我是说，你知道，他们总是说最坏的情况。然后我，我最后没事了，但它，他们非常。等等，你，但你现在还是，因为听了这个故事，我急得像热锅上的蚂蚁。所以你里面真的有钢钉吗？对，我有。他们没有把它们取出来。他们不打算把它们取出来。不，几年后我回去复诊时我说，
it's just bad to have in there. And they said, honestly, the surgery would be such a pain for you. Like if they're not bothering you, leave it. So I'm, I know. So can you run and jump and do anything? Oh yeah. Do you have fun scars on the bottom of your leg?
留在里面感觉不太好。他们说，老实说，手术对你来说会是个大麻烦。如果它们没有困扰你，就留着吧。所以，我，我知道。那你现在能跑步、跳跃和做任何事吗？哦，可以。你腿底部有有趣的疤痕吗？
Yeah, I do. That's cool. I got the blue scars. I don't have any good scars. You guys don't have any good scars? No. I do. Makes you feel like badass.
对，我有。挺酷的。我有蓝色的疤痕。我没有什么好疤痕。你们难道没有好疤痕吗？没有。我有。让你觉得自己像个狠角色。
I fell off the bunk bed when I was a kid. And I have on the side of my head. Oh, bless you. You're the drunk. Are the bunk bed. I've never met a guy that fell off the top bunk. You know, there's a little bars up there to help. I had a bar online.
我小时候从双层床上摔下来过。我的头部侧面有。哦，天哪。你是那个醉鬼。从双层床上。我从没见过从上铺掉下来的家伙。你知道上面有小栏杆可以帮忙的。我的那张床上有栏杆。
Although you just confirmed something that I've lawn suspected. Well, that you're atop. Yeah. I mean, I was gonna say it. And I was like, you know what, I'll say, I do have this scar. Wait, Shawnee, wait, there it is.
虽然你刚刚证实了我长期以来的一个猜想。好吧，证实了你是个1。对。我是说，我本来想说的。然后我想，你知道吗，我会说，我确实有这个疤痕。等等，肖妮，等等，它在那儿。
Yeah, that's called the belly button. Shawnee, you have lost so much fucking weight. Yeah, I'm not kidding. You lost so much weight. I know, but I'll gain it right away. Will, what did I get you for your blood? Shawnee has set me today, this fucking asshole. He set me for large things of ice cream.
对，那个叫肚脐眼。肖妮，你他妈瘦了好多。对，我没开玩笑。你瘦了好多。我知道，但我马上就会胖回去的。威尔，我给你带了什么血？肖妮今天给我带了，这个混蛋。他给我带了几大桶冰激凌。
And he said, this is what I used to get fat. To stay in what I used to get fat, happy birthday. what I eat to get fat. Happy birthday. And I'm like, you asshole. Cause now I'm going to eat it. If it's it's calling me if it's in the freezer, what kind of ice cream was it? It's the best chocolate and coffee and vanilla. Yeah. Huh.
他说，这是我以前用来发胖的。为了保持我以前发胖的状态，生日快乐。我吃这个来发胖。生日快乐。我当时想，你个混蛋。因为现在我要把它吃掉了。如果它在冰箱里一直召唤我，那是什么冰激凌？这是最好的巧克力、咖啡和香草味。对。哈。
The best. I can have creative. It's the best. You either go with the best or you don't. Have you you've gotten into it since then, right? Well, you'll pin it up. This morning, I had a cake last night with the kids. We had ice cream cake because that's my favorite
最棒的。我可以吃创造力的。这是最好的。要么选最好的，要么就不选。从那以后你开始吃了吗？好吧，你会把它吃光的。今天早上，我和孩子们昨晚吃了一个蛋糕。我们吃了冰激凌蛋糕，因为那是我的最爱，
and yellow cake with chocolate frosting. That's exactly right. Did you use the cake lady? No, no. Mercy made it who is here and she's a great, the cake lady's great, but Mercy makes an incredible cake. And so I will say, because we talked about it earlier, Jason, you going in, I ate the cake, I ate early with the kids
还有带巧克力糖霜的黄色蛋糕。完全正确。你们找了做蛋糕的那位女士吗？不，不。是莫西做的，她就在这里，她很棒，做蛋糕的女士也很棒，但莫西做的蛋糕简直绝了。所以我要说的是，因为我们之前聊过，杰森，你进去之后，我吃了蛋糕，我和孩子们很早就吃了，
and about 45 minutes after eating two pieces of cake as one of each. Night night. I went, no, another fucker and I went down, I came down into the gym and I were there for an hour. Oh, you did, you have to. Yeah, for you, did you zip into the rubber suit? I hard for an hour. Oh, you did. You have to. Yeah, for you. Did you just zip into the rubber suit? I said, yeah, of course, I always wear the rubber suit as you know.
在吃了两块蛋糕（每种各一块）大约45分钟后。晚安。我心想，去他妈的另一个，我走下来，我来到健身房练了一个小时。哦，你去了，你必须去。对，对你来说。你钻进橡胶衣里了吗？我拼命练了一个小时。哦，你去了。你必须去。对，你来说。你直接钻进橡胶衣里了吗？我说，对，当然，如你所知，我总是穿着橡胶衣。
We'll be right back. Smartness gets support from Helix. Okay. If you've listened to the podcast before, you know that I love me some Helix mattress. Okay? I got the Helix Midnight Lux mattress. And I sleep on it every night, whether I'm here or in Long Island, I'm always on my Helix Midnight Lux.
我们马上回来。Smartless由Helix赞助支持。好吧。如果你以前听过这个播客，你就知道我有多爱Helix床垫。好吗？我买的是Helix Midnight Lux床垫。我每天晚上都睡在上面，无论我是在这里还是在长岛，我总是睡在我的Helix Midnight Lux上。
And if I could like, you know, you see those like shows about those like crazy like billionaires or oil billionaires or whatever and they're like, they ship their cars around the world. If I ever got to be that guy, I'd just ship my mattress. I'd have my Helix midnight lux mattress like in the belly of a 747. That would be the ultimate sign of being full baller in my book. The Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Lux Collection, the newly released Helix Elite Collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids that my kids sleep on. Let's talk about the new high-end Helix Elite collection, shall we?
如果我可以像，你知道那些关于疯狂亿万富翁或石油大亨什么的节目，他们把汽车空运到世界各地。如果我也能成为那种人，我就会空运我的床垫。我会把我的Helix Midnight Lux床垫放在747客机的货舱里。在我看来，这才是真正的顶级大佬的标志。Helix系列提供20款独特的床垫，包括屡获殊荣的Lux系列、新发布的Helix Elite系列、专为高大身材睡眠者设计的床垫，甚至还有专为儿童制作的床垫，我的孩子们就睡在上面。让我们来聊聊全新的高端Helix Elite系列，好吗？
It includes six different mattress models, each tailored for specific sleep positions and firmness preferences. Plus, Helix mattresses all come with a 10 or 15 year warranty depending on the model. Helix is offering 20% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listener. Go to helixsleep.com slash smartless.
它包括六种不同的床垫型号，每种都针对特定的睡眠姿势和软硬偏好进行了量身定制。此外，根据型号的不同，所有Helix床垫都享有10年或15年的保修期。Helix为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单8折优惠以及两个免费枕头。访问helixsleep.com/smartless。
This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. With helix, better sleep starts now. Now. Smartness is brought to you in part by Macy's. Father's Day is June 18th, so get ahead of picking the perfect gift for the dads in your life. Whether they love the beach, a great barbecue, indulging in self-care, or somehow trying to combine all of the above as dads do, it's so easy to tailor your gift hunt to dad's tastes with Macy's gift finder. Check out these great ways to shop and more inspo at macy's.com slash gift finder. If you already know dad's signature cologne,ave workout gear, or most lusted after watch,
这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。有了Helix，优质睡眠从现在开始。现在。Smartless由梅西百货（Macy's）部分赞助播出。父亲节是6月18日，所以快为生命中的父亲们挑选完美的礼物吧。无论他们喜欢海滩、绝佳的烧烤、沉迷于自我保养，还是像爸爸们常做的那样试图将以上所有结合起来，通过梅西百货的礼品寻找器，根据爸爸的品味来定制你的礼物搜寻变得如此简单。访问macy's.com/gift finder查看这些绝佳的购物方式和更多灵感。如果你已经知道爸爸标志性的古龙水、运动装备或最渴望的手表，
shop by gift category, or shop by gift lists. Macy's has unique curated gift lists, like for the grill master, for the gamer dad, and for the sports fanatic. Plus, shop Macy's style crew members gift guides, like Thomas and Scott and Brian Moore. They've got gift picks curated just for you and can help spark ideas for even dads that say they don't need anything. By the way, Dad, if you're listening out there, I love you.
可以按礼品类别购物，或者按礼品清单购物。梅西百货拥有独特的精选礼品清单，比如为烧烤达人、游戏老爸和运动狂热粉准备的礼物。此外，还可以选购梅西百货时尚达人成员（如托马斯、斯科特和布莱恩·穆尔）的礼品指南。他们为你精心挑选了礼品，甚至能为那些说自己什么都不需要的爸爸们激发灵感。顺便说一句，爸爸，如果你在听的话，我爱你。
And where's my gift? Oh, I get it for him. So head on over to macy's.com slash gift finder to make this father's day an especially memorable one. One more time. That's macy's.com slash gift finder. Hey smart list listener. Amazon five star reviews present.
我的礼物呢？哦，我给他买。所以赶快前往macy's.com/gift finder，让这个父亲节变得格外难忘。再说一遍。网址是macy's.com/gift finder。嘿，Smartless的听众们。亚马逊五星好评呈献。
Feline Euphoria Our first customer review is from Sasha. She writes This robot vacuum is awesome. Never have the cats enjoyed something so much. They want another so they don't have to share. Best cat toy ever. It also cleans well. My allergies thank you, FySars. Thanks for being enthusiastic, Sasha.
猫咪的狂喜我们的第一个客户评论来自萨莎。她写道：这个扫地机器人太棒了。猫咪们还从没对什么东西这么感兴趣过。它们还想要一个，这样就不用分享了。史上最好的猫玩具。它还清理得很干净。我的过敏感谢你们，FySars。谢谢你的热情，萨莎。
Your charisma is overwhelming. That's how you make cleaning not suck, and that's how to make everyday better. Five stars. And now from Amazon Five Star Reviews present? Better than a wooden stake. This review is from a customer that goes by burnt toast. Burnt toast rights. Ever since this three pack of organic garlic was delivered, I have not seen a single vampire. from a customer that goes by burnt toast. Burnt toast rights.
你的个人魅力势不可挡。这就是让清洁不再痛苦的方法，也是让每一天变得更好的方法。五星好评。现在是亚马逊五星好评呈献？比木桩还要好。这条评论来自一个叫“烤焦的面包”的客户。“烤焦的面包”写道：
Ever since this three pack of organic garlic was delivered, I have not seen a single vampire. That cannot be a coincidence. Well, update my review of anything changes. Five stars. Wow. Lerious burnt toast. If it doesn't work, at least you got
自从这个三包装的有机大蒜送到后，我连一只吸血鬼都没见过。来自一个叫“烤焦的面包”的客户。“烤焦的面包”写道：自从这个三包装的有机大蒜送到后，我连一只吸血鬼都没见过。这绝不是巧合。好吧，如果有什么变化我会更新我的评论。五星好评。哇。搞笑的“烤焦的面包”。如果它不管用，至少你得到了
the beginnings of a good marinara. That's how you make every day better. Five stars. Real ambison, Cusper's real reviews, really. All right, back to the show. Kaylee, you always look so thin. Do you go crazy with junk food at all, ever? Oh, yeah.
制作美味意面酱的原料。这就是让每一天变得更好的方法。五星好评。真正的亚马逊，真实的客户，真实的评论，千真万确。好了，回到节目中。凯莉，你看起来总是那么瘦。你平时会疯狂吃垃圾食品吗？哦，会啊。
Oh, yeah? Do you? I mean, you know, I definitely do. Yeah, you know what I also kill? You've got great skin. I've always noticed that about you. Yes, thank you. Yeah, you've got really nice skin. Well, so nice.
哦，会吗？你会吗？我是说，你知道的，我绝对会。是的，你知道我还喜欢吃什么吗？你的皮肤真好。我一直注意到这一点。是的，谢谢。是的，你的皮肤真的很好。哇，太好了。
Thank you. I know it's really nice to have a work thing this morning and not have to do any hair and makeup whatsoever. It's very exciting. You know, that's on purpose. While we get to look at each other, we're, you know, it's like, I don't want anyone to have to go, oh, you hair and makeup whatsoever. It was very exciting. You know, that's on purpose. You know, while we get to look at each other, we're, you know, it's like, I don't want anyone to have to go, ah, hair and makeup and the whole, it's,
谢谢。我知道今天早上有个工作要忙，完全不用弄发型和化妆，这种感觉真的太棒了。这太令人兴奋了。你知道，那是故意的。当我们互相对视时，我们，你知道的，就像，我不想让任何人不得不说，哦，你的发型和化妆完全不用弄。这太令人兴奋了。你知道，那是故意的。你知道，当我们互相对视时，我们，你知道的，就像，我不想让任何人不得不说，啊，发型和化妆以及那一整套，
I mean, you guys have to look at me, but other than that, no one has to. Why do you have such good skin, do you stay out of the sun? No, I don't stay out of the sun. I've got quite a skin regimen on my little products, but I'll, but you were very good about putting on some block when you were almost a semi pro tennis star when you were a youngster.
我是说，你们得看着我，但除此之外，没人需要看。为什么你的皮肤这么好，你不出门晒太阳吗？不，我没有不出门晒太阳。我有自己的一套皮肤护理流程和一些小产品，但是我会，但你年轻时作为准职业网球选手，涂防晒霜可是一丝不苟。
Yes. Wait, what? Let's get it. Yes, she decided. She decided at 16. I could go this way or we could try acting. You were a tennis pro. I did play tennis my whole junior's when I was in,
是的。等等，什么？让我们了解一下。是的，她决定的。她16岁时决定：我可以走这条路，或者我们可以尝试表演。你曾是一名网球职业选手。我整个青少年时期都在打网球，当时我，
yeah, that's all I did. And I really thought I was going to be a professional tennis player when I was much younger. Where was's all I did. And I really thought I was gonna be a professional tennis player when I was much younger. Where was that? They didn't hear it. Camerillo. Yeah, in Camerillo.
对，我只做这个。我真的很年轻的时候，我以为我会成为一名职业网球选手。那是在哪儿？他们没听到。卡马里奥。对，在卡马里奥。
And then, the Southern California, and then, but I traveled all over the country and I loved it. And then realized, oh my God, you, and I was auditioning and working. And then I got my first show. And I was like, to be a professional tennis player, you'd really just do that. I thought I don't know if I can give myself to both.
然后，南加州，然后，但我走遍了全国各地，我非常喜欢它。然后我意识到，天哪，你，当时我正在试镜和工作。然后我得到了我的第一部剧。当时我想，要成为一名职业网球选手，你真的得全身心投入。我觉得我不知道自己能否两边都兼顾。
So I was like, I'm never going to play again. I put my rackets down at like 16, but I played very competitively for years and years as a young teen and traveled all over and I loved it. Yeah, I loved it. So hard. That takes so much training and so much dedication. I loved it. And you still play a tiny bit?
所以我当时想，我再也不打了。我在16岁左右放下了球拍，但作为年轻的青少年，我连续多年进行高强度的竞技比赛，到处旅行，我非常喜欢它。是的，我太喜欢了。太难了。那需要那么多的训练和专注。我太喜欢了。那你现在还打一点点吗？
So I stopped for years. You know, I think when you're competitive in any sport, it's not fun. The fun kind of leaves a little bit. So to play for fun was not something I wanted to do. So over COVID, my girlfriend, who is my oldest friend, who is my doubles partner, when we were really young, she's like, let's start playing again. So we started playing doubles together during COVID and like entered tournaments since it was hysterical and had, I loved it. Because it's socially distant, right? That's
我停了好几年。你知道，我认为当你在一项运动中很有竞争力时，它就不好玩了。乐趣有点消失了。所以为了好玩而去打球并不是我想做的事。所以在新冠疫情期间，我的女友（也是我最好的朋友，我们很小的时候就是双打搭档）说：“我们重新开始打球吧。”于是我们在新冠疫情期间开始一起打双打，甚至还报名参加了比赛，这太滑稽了，我太喜欢了。因为保持社交距离，对吧？
why you could do a during COVID. That's why we'll go back into golf, son of a bitch. So yeah, I heard that you had some rage, but that was interesting story. Oh, real issues. Which time did you hear about? That was interesting story. Oh, real issues. Which time did you hear about? You jump up the guy who did a charge of Tesla? That's one of the greatest stories ever. Now, see, now that's a perfect example of me two years ago versus now.
这就是为什么你能在新冠期间打球的原因。这就是我们要重新开始打高尔夫球的原因，你这个王八蛋。所以，我听说你有点暴脾气，那是个有趣的故事。哦，真的有问题。你听说了哪一次？那是个有趣的故事。哦，真的有问题。你听说了哪一次？你冲上去对付那个开特斯拉插队的家伙？那是史上最棒的故事之一。看吧，现在这就是我两年前与现在的完美对比。
I exit myself from the situation before I'm accountable for my money. So, wait a minute. I will separate myself from people and just deal with them. I will say that he did approach all of us who were playing with him yesterday and said, one by one, I'm not joking. And he said, hey man, I'm really sorry that I've been kind of grinding and cranky today.
在我要为自己的冲动负责之前，我会先让自己脱离那种状况。所以，等等。我会让自己与人保持距离，然后自己处理。我要说的是，昨天他确实走近了所有和我们一起打球的人，一个接一个地，我没开玩笑。他说：“嘿，伙计，我真的很抱歉今天有点急躁和脾气暴躁。”
And he went and I heard him say it to the other guys. And I thought, fuck this is a new Jason. That's great. This is my beautiful wife Amanda is teaching me how to be a better man. Kaylee, I have a question about the guys. That's good. Sweet. It's my beautiful wife Amanda is teaching me how to be a better man. Kaley, I have a question about the guys don't fight.
然后他走过去，我听到他对其他几个人说了。然后我想，操，这是一个全新的杰森。太棒了。这是我美丽的妻子阿曼达在教我如何成为一个更好的男人。凯莉，我关于这几个家伙有个问题。那很好。太棒了。这是我美丽的妻子阿曼达在教我如何成为一个更好的男人。凯莉，我关于这几个家伙不吵架有个问题。
We want to talk to Kaley so bad. I just want to know if she had rage when you played when you. Yes, was your worst moment? Did you ever say you can't be serious? Oh my God.
我们太想和凯莉谈谈了。我只想知道你演戏时她有没有生过气。是的，你最糟糕的时刻是什么时候？你有没有说过“你不是认真的吧”？天哪。
Are you I broke so many rackets. I had a real bad attitude actually. I to this day you don't want to play Scrabble with me. I am the worst. I am the worst. You don't want to play Scrabble?
你是……我弄坏了好多球拍。其实我当时的态度真的很差。直到今天，你都不想跟我玩拼字游戏。我是最差的。我是最差的。你不想玩拼字游戏吗？
Kick your ass and Scrabble. That's exactly how I get to. I lose my shit. I love to win. I don't fuck around. It's not a joke to me. Game night is not, no one wants to let me participate in Game night because I don't make it fun for anybody.
在拼字游戏里打得你落花流水。我就是那样的。我会气急败坏。我喜欢赢。我可不是闹着玩的。对我来说这不是个玩笑。游戏之夜不是……没人想让我参与游戏之夜，因为我让大家玩得都不开心。
Do you have a game night going right now? Like in this moment. No, I don't. I'm like a gentleman. Like a gentleman. No, I don't. Do you have a game night going right now? Like in this moment. No, I don't know. I don't know. Like in the show. Like in the show. Like in the show. Like in the show.
你现在有游戏之夜吗？就在此时此刻。不，我没有。像个绅士一样。像个绅士一样。不，我没有。你现在有游戏之夜吗？就在此时此刻。不，我不知道。我不知道。就像在节目里一样。就像在节目里一样。就像在节目里一样。就像在节目里一样。
Sometimes you do game nights. I like games. We love game nights. We are obsessed. But again. When you say we were talking about Tom Palfrey or we know we in Tom Palfrey, we love game nights. Easy on the eyes.
有时你们会搞游戏之夜。我喜欢游戏。我们超爱游戏之夜。我们迷得不行。不过话说回来。当你说我们时，我们是在说汤姆·佩尔弗里，还是说我们……在汤姆·佩尔弗里，我们超爱游戏之夜。真是养眼。
What a guy. I love that. Is that your guy? Is Tom Palfrey? Is Tom Palfrey your guy? Is that your relationship? Tom Palfrey's Pell for your guy? Is that your guy? Tom Fries, my guy. We love game nights.
这哥们儿。我太喜欢了。那是你的菜吗？是汤姆·佩尔弗里吗？汤姆·佩尔弗里是你的菜吗？那是你们的关系吗？汤姆·佩尔弗里是你的菜吗？那是你的菜吗？汤姆·弗赖斯，我的菜。我们超爱游戏之夜。
Okay. I met him because of, it's really, I have to think Jason. They met at the Ozark rap party. If you can believe that. Oh, sweet way. You're the reason I met him. Yes. Yeah.
好吧。我认识他是因为……说实话，我得想想，杰森。他们是在《黑钱胜地》的杀青派对上认识的。如果你敢相信的话。哦，真甜蜜。你是我认识他的原因。是的。对。
Now, walk us through the story. Did he know you were coming or did you know he was going to be there? Was there any sort of setup there at all? I don't remember. I knew. So we have the same. I'm sure you've heard this story many times, but we have the same manager. And she, the December, that past December, she had said, I want to set, I want to set
现在，给我们讲讲这个故事吧。他知道你要来吗？还是你知道他会在那儿？那里有什么刻意的安排吗？我不记得了。我知道。所以我们有同一个……我确信你已经听过这个故事很多遍了，但我们有同一个经纪人。而在那年十二月，过去的十二月，她曾说过，我想安排……我想安排
you up with someone that I know. And I said, it was too soon after my last relationship. I was like, no, I'm not ready. She goes noted fine. So in April, I was going to New York to promote flight attendant and my manager, Andrea was like, yeah, so you're sure, yeah, you can edit the applause in later. That would be great. Yep. And we put a little in for Big Bang earlier. Go ahead. Thank you. No, thank you. These are great shows. These are thank you. Please continue.
你和我认识的一个人见个面。我说，这离我的上一段感情结束还太快了。我说，不，我还没准备好。她说，记下了，好吧。所以在四月份，我要去纽约宣传《空乘危机》，我的经纪人安德里亚就说，好吧，所以你确定，对，你可以在后面把掌声剪辑进去。那就太好了。是的。我们之前还为《生活大爆炸》做过一点宣传。请继续。谢谢。不，谢谢。这些都是好节目。这些是……谢谢。请继续。
So I, um, she decided to come with me to New York to just hang out. And she was actually, I'm gonna, my other client is going, I'm gonna see my other client there and she didn't even really say it was Tom, but she said I'm gonna go to Ozark, premier and it's during the week and do you wanna come with me? And it wasn't.
所以我……嗯，她决定陪我去纽约随便逛逛。而且她其实……我要去……我的另一个客户要去，我要在那儿见我的另一个客户，她甚至没有真正说是汤姆，但她说我要去《黑钱胜地》的首映礼，而且是在工作日，你想跟我一起去吗？其实不是。
And you were like, what's Ozark? Nobody knows what that is. For 100% I had no, I never heard the show. I didn't wanna go. And so she said, come with me. And I was like, I was like the show. I didn't want to go. And so she said, come with me. And I was like, I was like, okay. And I went with her and got all dolled up. I knew I would meet him, of course,
而你的反应是：什么是《黑钱胜地》？根本没人知道那是什么。100%我不知道，我从来没听说过这个节目。我不想去。所以她说，跟我一起来吧。我说……我当时说，这个节目。我不想去。所以她说，跟我一起来吧。我说……我当时说，好吧。我跟她一起去了，还盛装打扮了一番。我当然知道我会见到他，
but it didn't occur to me about anything else. And when I got there, we were a little late. And so everyone was piling into the theater. I didn't have a minute to meet him. And I was actually standing near the waiting the line in the restroom. I was faced away and I overheard, you know, he's got a very sexy voice.
但我根本没想过其他任何事。等我到那儿的时候，我们稍微迟到了。所以大家都蜂拥挤进剧院。我根本没有时间跟他见面。其实我当时正站在洗手间外排队等候。我背对着那边，无意中听到……你知道的，他有着非常性感的嗓音。
Mr. Tom Palfrey. Yeah, it does. And I overheard him say to our manager, where is this Kayleigh? And I turned around, and it was like, She's right and funny, waiting to take a dump. Yes. And you were like,
汤姆·佩尔弗里先生。是的，确实有。我无意中听到他对我们的经纪人说：“这个凯莉在哪儿？”我转过身去，心想：她正站在那儿，好笑地等着拉屎呢。是的。你的反应是……
That's what I said. Yeah, that's what I said. Yeah, that's what I said to him. And he thought it was really cool that I was so open. No, I saw him and it was like this very strange like the world kind of stopped. Really? Yeah, it was really wild. He gave me this huge bear hug.
我就是这么说的。对，我就是这么说的。对，我就是这么对他说。他觉得我很酷，因为我那么坦率。不，我看到他时，就有一种非常奇怪的感觉，仿佛世界停止了转动。真的吗？是的，真的太疯狂了。他给了我一个巨大的熊抱。
And like I said, there were so many people piling and it wasn't a moment to really talk. And so we all just have nice to meet you. Yeah. I mean, he's just real easy with that quick smile, right? He's got a nice, that last smile. Come on. Yeah.
就像我说的，有太多人挤进去了，根本没时间好好聊聊。所以我们都只是说很高兴认识你。我的意思是，他带着那种标志性的灿烂微笑，真的很随和，对吧？他笑起来很好看，那种最后的微笑。拜托。是的。
Infectious. And so how many years has that been going on? We've been together for one year. We got pregnant two months in. We have a baby. We were like, boom, boom, boom. We're in sync. Let's go back to my room.
极具感染力。那这种状态已经持续多少年了？我们在一起一年了。两个月就怀孕了。我们有了个孩子。我们的节奏就像是，轰，轰，轰。我们太同步了。咱们回我房间吧。
Yeah. You know, we're not 20 anymore. We were like, we doing this or not. So Matilda is a full month. Two months. Five weeks old today. Oh my gosh. Congratulations. Thank you. You had a baby five weeks ago. Can you believe that? No, I can't. I know. And look at you. You don't look like you had a bed like you're just you look great. Tom. Tom actually carried it. Oh, no kidding. No kidding. Yeah, yeah. Oh, that's a good man. They're very progressive. Tom would carry the baby. He is that obsessed. But how do you have energy?
是的。你知道的，我们不再是20岁的人了。我们当时想，我们要不要来真的。所以玛蒂尔达现在整整一个月了。两个月。今天五周大。哦，天哪。恭喜。谢谢。你五周前刚生了个孩子。你敢相信吗？不，我不敢。我知道。看看你。你看起来一点也不像刚生过孩子，你看上去状态太棒了。汤姆。其实是汤姆怀的。哦，不是吧。不是吧。对，对。哦，那是个好男人。他们非常前卫。汤姆会怀上孩子。他就是那么着迷。不过你怎么会有精力？
Like aren't you exhausted? Or do you have one of those good babies that sleeps all the time? She, no, she's pretty awesome. Look, I'm not going to lie. We have some very nice help. Yes, I feel even guilty saying it, but we have very nice help, which is why I can like, it's a, I have my relationship is so survived because we have all this help. Yeah, listen, one of them. Oh my god. I mean, yeah, I mean, if he can, if he can, if he got in laws or whatever, I think anything such a big fan of like, it makes you better. Think about this.
难道你不累吗？还是你们有一个那种从头睡到尾的乖宝宝？她……不，她挺棒的。听着，我不会撒谎。我们请了非常棒的帮手。是的，说这话我甚至觉得有点内疚，但我们确实请了非常棒的帮手，这就是为什么我能够……这是一段……我的关系能维持下来，完全是因为我们有这些帮手。是的，听着，其中一个。哦，天哪。我是说，是的，我是说，如果他能……如果他有岳父岳母什么的，我认为任何像这样的超级粉丝……它能让你变得更好。想想看。
In the old days, it used to be people who all lived with their families in the old time. Yeah. And you had family around and family would help out. And you'd have siblings and parents and grandparents and stuff. And it would all end up. And now, at the end of your rope. Yeah, and now it's different. No, exactly.
在过去，过去的人们都是一大家子住在一起的。是的。身边有家人，家人会帮忙。你会有兄弟姐妹、父母和祖父母之类的人。所有这一切最终都会……而现在，你已经筋疲力尽了。是的，而现在情况不同了。不，确实如此。
And it's great to, my mom is here this morning. She was like, so excited. I had something I had to do so she could hang out with a baby for an hour. So it's like, it's great to my mom is here this morning. She was like so excited. I had something I had to do so she could hang out with a baby for an hour. So it's like, it's the best. Now does she mom, does she mom Matilda like you would or do you guys have like a little bit of tension like a don't start trouble?
而且太棒了，我妈妈今天早上在这儿。她超级兴奋。我有点事要做，所以她可以陪宝宝呆一个小时。所以这感觉……我妈妈今天早上在这儿，真是太棒了。她超级兴奋。我有点事要做，所以她可以陪宝宝呆一个小时。所以这感觉……真是太棒了。现在她，妈妈，她带玛蒂尔达的方式像你一样吗？还是你们之间有点小摩擦，比如“别挑起事端”？
No, yeah, my mom honestly, my mom is the best. And actually so is Tom's mom. They are like, they come in, they help, they don't overstep it. Do they get along? Do the moms. Oh my God, we're so lucky. They all oddly look like each other too.
不，是的，我妈妈老实说，我妈妈是最好的。其实汤姆的妈妈也是。她们会过来帮忙，但绝不越界。她们合得来吗？这两位妈妈。天哪，我们太幸运了。说来也怪，她们长得还挺像彼此的。
And they're they become very close. We're just like really lucky. They are. You're very lucky. We're very lucky. That's great. I know. I know five weeks old.
而且她们变得非常亲密。我们简直是……超级幸运。她们确实是。你太幸运了。我们太幸运了。那太棒了。我知道。我知道，才五周大。
Do you want more kids? Yeah, we do. Sean, are you moving a couple? Sean, yeah, I'm moving. Do you have any links you moving a couple? Shama yeah, I'm moving a Do you have any links you could send her Yeah, the dark web all right, so let's start with now Big bang is something that was a big bang right with that was a phenomenon
你还想要孩子吗？是的，我们要。肖恩，你要搬家了吗？肖恩，对，我要搬家。你有什么链接可以发给她吗？暗网……好吧，让我们从《生活大爆炸》开始，那是一个大爆炸，对吧？那是一个轰动一时的现象。
No, I'm 10 12 seasons 12 12 seasons. I mean that's incredible now could you have could you have, could you have gone, kept going, or was it like, this is the right time to end this? You know, I'll be honest with you, and I've talked about this before. We truly are group of actors. We thought we were 100% doing the 13th season. We thought, we'll do a 13th,
不，我有10季、12季……12季。我的意思是这太不可思议了。现在，你们当时……你们当时能继续演下去吗？还是说，这正是剧集完结的绝佳时机？你知道的，实话实说，我以前也谈过这个。我们真的……我们这群演员当时100%认为我们会拍第13季。我们觉得，我们会拍第13季，
that'll be the last one, but, you know, and then, and this story is not new. I'm not giving it a thing. I mean, Jim really did. Jim Parsons really wanted to be done and he was kind of the first person to call it. And we didn't know that was happening. We kind of all thought we were gonna do another season
那将是最后一季，但是，你知道的，然后……这个故事也不是什么新鲜事。我没打算隐瞒什么。我的意思是，吉姆是真的……吉姆·帕森斯真的很想收手了，他算是第一个提出不干的人。我们当时并不知道会这样。我们其实都以为我们会再拍一季，
but we heard it at the beginning of season 12, basically after our second table read, we were told this was gonna be it. And it was actually kind of, I mean, as sad as we all were and a little bit shocked, it was cool because then we had like a whole season to really be in the moment, play.
但我们在第12季刚开始时就听说了，基本上是在我们第二次围读剧本之后，我们被告知这将是最后一季。说实话，这感觉……尽管我们所有人都很难过，还有点震惊，但它其实挺酷的，因为那样的话我们就有整整一季的时间真正投入其中，尽情表演。
Yeah, it was cool. We could kind of like slow. We was Jim Show. Was it Jim Show? Originally, yeah, then it kind of became more of an ensemble show. Yeah, he just was, he didn't, he was done. And we were all just, oh my God,
是的，这很酷。我们可以稍微放慢……这是吉姆的节目吗？原本是的，后来它在某种程度上更像是一部群戏。是的，他只是……他不想演了。我们所有人都“哦，天哪”，
it was so shocking. But then I think over the few weeks, it was like, okay, maybe this is the right thing. And honestly, I mean, for me, I wouldn't have even done, I don't know, flight attendant would have happened. Like the timing was actually amazing. Everything happens for a reason, yeah. A totally, so we were, it was fine.
太令人震惊了。但随后我想在接下来的几周里，大家觉得，好吧，也许这是对的。老实说，对我来说，我甚至不会去演……我不知道，《空乘危机》还会不会发生。所以这个时机其实太棒了。一切发生都是有原因的。完全如此，所以我们……没问题。
But that routine of, in front of a wide audience, that is a, do you miss that? I mean, it's so great, right? I loved it. I loved the audience. I thought it would, I loved obviously, I loved the schedule. It was great.
但是那种在广大观众面前表演的日常，那是一种……你会怀念吗？我的意思是，那太棒了，对吧？我喜欢。我喜欢观众。我想我会……我当然喜欢，我喜欢那种时间表。那太棒了。
I'm happy now not doing it, but it was such incredible memories. I mean, some of those live shows were some of the best nights of my life for sure. I mean, my dad never missed a deep. He was an audience every week. Every single year. Yeah. He had his own chair at the back of the audience.
我现在不干了我也很开心，但那真的是不可思议的回忆。我的意思是，其中一些现场演出绝对是我一生中最美好的夜晚之一。我的意思是，我爸爸从不缺席任何一场。他每周都在观众席里。每一场。是的。他在观众席后面有他自己的专属椅子。
Yes. Couldn't sit in it. The angel could not even, he was standing the whole time. And what we do before each show with the little thumbs up. He gave me a thumbs up for curtain call. Every time I came out and the crew, the whole cast would do it too in the crew. Yes, the crew started obviously with my dad. So everyone would do this like thumbs up for my dad. I mean out in the crew. The whole cast would do it too in the crew. Yes, the crew started obviously, my dad.
是的。都不能坐在上面。天使甚至都不能坐，他全程站着。我们在每场演出前都会做的那个小动作，竖起大拇指。每次我走出来谢幕时，他都会给我竖大拇指，剧组人员和全体演员也会这么做。是的，剧组人员显然是从我爸爸开始的。所以每个人都会这样为我爸爸竖起大拇指。我是说在剧组里。全体演员也会这么做，还有剧组人员。是的，剧组人员显然是从我爸爸开始的……
So everyone would do this like thumbs up for my dad. I mean, he was there, I'm not kidding, every, every shownight for 12 years. My dad came to, none of them, he didn't come to any of them. What are you going to do? Yeah, he didn't come to me. No, he went to Kaley's shows.
所以每个人都会这样为我爸爸竖起大拇指。我是说，他当时在场，我没开玩笑，12年来每一个演出之夜都在。我爸爸来了……他们一个都没来，他一场都没来。你打算怎么办？是的，他没来看我。不，他去看了凯莉的演出。
You're doing it. Sean, your dad went to every one of Kaley's shows. He was so wonderful. He drove for that. He had a chair. He was so into it. What Kaley, Kaley, how many so wonderful. He drove her dad. He had a chair. So into it. What Kaley, how many episodes did you guys do a big bang? Oh my God. You know what? 100. It was something like that. I actually don't remember the number. 22 times 13. Quick.
你正在做这件事。肖恩，你爸爸去看了凯莉的每一场演出。他太棒了。他开车去看。他有一把椅子。他太投入了。凯莉，凯莉，你们一共拍了多少集《生活大爆炸》？哦，天哪。你知道吗？100集。差不多是这个数字。其实我记不清具体数字了。22乘以13。快算算。
We did 20. I'm sure there were some years there were 24 and yeah, 250. Something like that. It was up there. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. 100. Oh yeah, yeah. That's so impressive. And it's so, in a, I angel, I'm not just of the schedule, but of like, kind of what Jason was saying, like being able to go and do that every week in front of the audience. That's so, what people don't understand
我们拍了20……我敢肯定有些年份拍了24集，还有……250集。差不多吧。差不多就是那个量级。是的。是的。是的。100集。哦，对，对。太令人印象深刻了。而且在某种程度上……天使啊，不仅仅是因为拍摄时间表，而是像杰森刚才说的，能够每周去那里在观众面前表演。那是如此……人们不理解的是，
is how much fun. Yeah, a live audience. He is so free. It's so fun. Now, one, one, we're a kid, and we're at home, we're playing, we's so fun. Now, one more kid at home were playing tennis. Where did the whole thing for acting come from? Was Gary or Lane?
有多么开心。是的，现场观众。他太自由了。太有趣了。现在，一个……一个，当我们还是个孩子，我们在家里玩，我们在打网球。演戏这件事到底是怎么开始的？是加里还是莱恩？
Lane? Am I saying that right? Yeah, Lane. Yes. Yes. Were they into acting at all? Like, who, how did this come about? No, it was concrete.
莱恩？我没说错吧？对，莱恩。是的。是的。他们对演戏感兴趣吗？是谁，这事是怎么促成的？不，是混凝土……
No, I did a lot of different things when I was younger. You know, my, I would go in auditions, like as I played tennis, I went to these camps that I loved. Like, it was, I had a million things I was doing. So, and it was just, it was smart because nothing ever really got me down. Like, I wasn't like a child actor who was just acting.
不，我小时候做过很多不同的事情。你知道的，我……我会去试镜，比如我打网球，我会去我非常喜欢的这些营地。就像，我当时有一百万件要做的事。所以，这很聪明，因为从来没有什么真正让我沮丧过。就像我不是那种只会演戏的童星，
Like, I just, it was another thing that I did. And then if that didn't, I had a tennis lesson or I went away for the week at like, they just constantly had me in all these different things and until it got a little bit more serious. And I remember very clearly they sat me down. It was pretty young. I probably was not even eight or nine years old.
就像，这只是我做的另一件事。如果这个不行，我还有网球课，或者我会去参加一周的夏令营……他们一直让我参加所有这些不同的活动，直到这件事变得稍微严肃了一点。我记得非常清楚，他们让我坐下来。当时我还很小。我可能连八九岁都没有，
And they sat me down there like, you're this is a real job. Like do you wanna keep doing this? And I, there was like not a doubt in my mind. I was like, this is a real job. Like, do you want to keep doing this? And I, there was like, not a doubt in my mind. I was like, this is what I want to do. They're like, are you sure? Yeah. Yeah.
他们让我坐下来，对我说：“这是一个真正的行业。你想继续做下去吗？”我当时……我心里甚至没有一丝怀疑，我说：“这是一个真正的行业。你想继续做下去吗？”我当时……我心里甚至没有一丝怀疑，我说：“这就是我想做的事。”他们说：“你确定吗？”是的。是的。
No, sorry, I wanted to be an actor. Oh, yeah, yeah. So keep playing tennis. Keep doing both. Have the second thing. We didn't, they weren't comfortable with me just doing the acting thing. What was the first, what was the first real gig
不，抱歉，我想当演员。哦，对，对。所以继续打网球。两样都做。得有第二条出路。我们……他们对我只专注于演戏可不太放心。第一份工作是什么，第一份真正有收入的工作是什么？
with the first, first real paying like, Cheerios, something like that? I mean, I did do all those commercials. I was the Barbie girl gig? Were the first real paying like, Cheerios, something like that? I mean, I did do all those commercials. I was the Barbie girl for like two years. I did like a handful of Barbie commercials. I was an other single one. Do you still have them on tape? Oh, yeah, somewhere.
第一份真正有收入的工作是拍《甜麦圈》广告之类的吗？我的意思是，我确实拍了所有那些商业广告。我当了大约两年的芭比女孩？第一份真正有收入的工作是拍《甜麦圈》广告之类的吗？我的意思是，我确实拍了所有那些商业广告。我当了大约两年的芭比女孩，拍了好几个芭比娃娃的广告。我是唯一的一个。你现在还留着录像带吗？哦，是的，在某个地方。
My mom has some sugar. I want to see those. I was the Oscar-Mire. I sang the Oscar-Mire song. I did the EW always. Give us a little. Yeah. Yeah.
我妈妈留着一些糖。我想看看那些。我是奥斯卡·迈耶的女孩。我唱了奥斯卡·迈耶的歌。我拍了永远的EW……给我们来一小段。是的。是的。
Well, I don't know what to spell. I wish I were an Oscar-Mire. Wee-Nire we. Exactly. Yes. You sang that in the commercial. Yeah, had to do the whole thing and play against a fake little weiner. Anybody? Anybody? Anybody? I was tossing that up for you. Will I? I know. No, no, no. All right. So then, so then you're you're you're acting along, and your, was there a thought, well, maybe I should go to college too, to have, make sure I have a backup or something. Just go to college.
嗯，我不知道怎么拼。我真希望我是个奥斯卡·迈耶的热狗人。热狗人，我们……没错。是的。你在广告里唱过那个。是的，必须把整首歌唱完，还要对着一个假的小热狗演戏。有人吗？有人吗？有人吗？我这是在给你抛梗呢。我会吗？我知道。不，不，不。好吧。所以呢……所以你一直在演戏，然后，有没有想过，好吧，也许我也应该去上大学，以确保我有一个备选方案什么的？去上大学吧。
Hated school, so that was the one thing. I just was not grade school seventh, eighth, and into early, I said, I asked my parents if I could get my GED, and I was very clear on my guys. This is not for me, like, I know my future is not going to be. I don't, I hated school. I just hated it. I didn't even.
讨厌学校，所以那是唯一的一点。我就是不喜欢文法学校的七年级、八年级一直到早期……我问父母我能不能去考个普通教育发展证书（GED），我对我的伙伴们表达得非常清楚。这不适合我，我知道我的未来不会是……我不想……我讨厌学校。我就是讨厌它。我甚至……
I don't need trigonometry. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. It wasn't for me. Even when I had to do set school, like the devastation that I had to, like, leave set to go do school. It just killed my soul. Sure, I think so.
我不需要三角函数。是的。没错，就是这样。这不适合我。甚至当我不得不去片场的学校上课时……不得不离开片场去上学那种痛苦，简直扼杀了我的灵魂。当然，我想是的。
So they let, they were like, I can't believe they listened to me. It's kind of amazing. They let me get my GED. What Gary's very permissive. He was like, go ahead. That's always been the bump on you. They were so cool about it.
所以他们放任……他们当时的心情是，我不敢相信他们听了我的话。这简直太神奇了。他们让我去考了GED。加里非常纵容。他当时说，去吧。那一直都是你的槽点。他们对此看得太开了。
I'm such an idiot. Were your parents actors too? No. Oh. No, they were not. My mom was stayed at home with us since the minute we were born. Jay, how do you know their names, Gary?
我简直是个白痴。你的父母也是演员吗？不是。哦。不是，他们不是。我妈从我们出生的那一刻起就一直是全职妈妈。杰伊，你怎么知道他们的名字，加里？
I'm just doing bits. I get a little bit of research. I know their names and I. I'm just, you know, I'm doing bits, you know, get a little bit of research. I know their names and I'm asking if I know them. It's fun. Okay. Okay. Gary was a realtor. Gary was in residential real estate. Oh, mostly in the Camarillo area. Yes. Yes. Wow. These are guesses. These are guys. He was a, he was a, um, paramedic firefighter actually for a very long time. Wow. Yeah, went into real estate, and my mom, stayed home. I mean, my mom truly drove me all around.
我只是在抛梗。我做了一点点功课。我知道他们的名字，而且……我只是，你知道的，我在抛梗，你知道的，做了一点点功课。我知道他们的名字，我在问我是不是认识他们。这挺有意思的。好吧。好吧。加里是个房产经纪人。加里从事住宅房地产行业。哦，主要在卡马里奥地区。是的。是的。哇。这些都是瞎猜的。这些是瞎猜的。他以前是个……其实他当了很长时间的消防员兼急救人员。哇。是的，后来转行做房地产，我妈则是全职妈妈。我的意思是，我妈真的是开车带着我到处跑。
Like, that's all she did was try to get out of the house. Brothers and sisters. My sister, yeah, my sister, three years younger, my sister, three years younger. Did the same thing or no? She did. She loved school, though. She went to high school.
真的，她做的一切就是为了带我出门。有兄弟姐妹吗？我有个妹妹，对，我妹妹比我小三岁，我妹妹比我小三岁。也走这条路吗？没有。她走过。不过她很喜欢学校。她上了高中。
She was like, you know, a little social butterfly, but she's an actor, too. She has an amazing voice. She's incredible. Yeah, she was on mass, butterfly, but she's, she's an actor too. She has an amazing voice. She's incredible. Yeah. She was on mass, no, not mass singer, um, the voice. The voice. Yeah.
她就像是一个……有点社交花蝴蝶的感觉，但她也是个演员。她有一副令人惊叹的嗓音。她太厉害了。是的，她上过……社交花蝴蝶，但她也是个演员。她有一副令人惊叹的嗓音。她太厉害了。是的。她上过《蒙面歌王》……不，不是《蒙面歌王》，嗯，《美国好声音》。《美国好声音》。是的。
Oh, wow. Really? Oh, the voice. Uh-huh. And there are a couple of rounds. Now with, uh, with, with Gary's history and medicine, do you know CPR? What's funny is we just learned CPR because of this baby. Right.
哦，哇。真的吗？哦，《美国好声音》。嗯哼。还闯过了好几轮。现在，鉴于加里的医学背景，你知道心肺复苏术（CPR）吗？有趣的是，因为这个孩子，我们刚刚学了CPR。对。
So we had these private CPR sessions, which by the way was terrifying. I don't know if you, they're showing you how to do like the CPR on the baby. That was, I'm like, I'm never gonna remember this, by the way, I'm so traumatized by even doing it on the fake baby. So we did technically learn, but.
所以我们上了这些私人的CPR课程，顺便说一句，那过程简直吓死人了。我不知道你们……他们会教你如何在婴儿身上做CPR。那真的……我说，我绝不可能记住这些，顺便说一句，我对在假婴儿身上做这个都有心理阴影了。所以我们从技术上来说确实学过了，但是……
I'm not a two, but I think I need to refresh her because I think I may have forgotten maybe, because like you forget one little component, it's useless. You can see Sean and Will, do you guys know CPR? No, I don't, but I can guess. But wait, how to do it? But wait, in a pinch? Yeah, in a pinch I could probably just guess what to do.
我算不上什么专家，但我认为我需要复习一下，因为我觉得我可能已经忘光了，因为只要你忘了一个小细节，它就毫无用处了。你可以看看肖恩和威尔，你们懂CPR吗？不，我不懂，但我可以猜。不过等等，怎么做？不过等等，在紧要关头？是的，在紧要关头我大概可以瞎猜该怎么做。
You just plug the nose, make out with the person, and then pound on the shot. Yeah, you're right. It's a Saturday, yeah. But wait, I always thought it was so crazy in like movies and TV shows when people, you know, are passed out or whatever dying and people have to do CPR and they're pounding on their chest. How does the actor not like move? Like I'd be like, ow, ow, ow, ow every time.
你只要捏住鼻子，跟那个人舌吻，然后猛砸他的胸口。是的，你说得对。是个周六，对。但等等，我一直觉得在电影和电视剧里，当人们昏迷不醒或者快要死掉时，别人必须对他们做CPR，还要猛砸他们的胸口，这太疯狂了。演员怎么能做到不乱动呢？如果是我，每次都会喊“哎哟，哎哟，哎哟，哎哟”。
Yeah, I mean, like you're the worst actor. God. Well, I think the, I remember we had to do CPR in one in a scene in flight and I mean they're pretty padded I don't think we're just soking people in the chat Sean do you want to just you this is like a question hey we got a question from the audience over here For showbiz when you guys are shooting a movie is it real with what are you doing now? It's under that I always wonder that because it looks like what what are you doing? You're pounding. And also when you're breathing when you're breathing into their mouth
对，我的意思是……就像你是最烂的演员一样。天哪。好吧，我觉得……我记得我们在《空乘危机》里有一场戏必须做CPR，我的意思是，他们身上其实垫了很厚的东西，我想我们并不是在真砸别人的胸口。肖恩，你想不想直接……这就像是个问题，嘿，我们这儿有观众提问：对于演艺圈来说，当你们在拍电影时，你们在做的事是真的吗？就是你现在在做的那种？我一直很好奇，因为看起来像是在……你在做什么？你在猛砸。还有，当你在呼吸时，当你在他们嘴里吹气时，
in a TV show or movie, and how are you not going, like, you know, how do you like? What about I went down to give you mouth to mouth on Murder Bill. And you just, I thought you were going to let me and then you didn't. And then I was like, wait, you're going to let me.
在电视剧或电影里，你怎么能做到不发出声音……你知道的，你怎么能……？还记得我为了《谋杀比尔》给你做人工呼吸吗？你当时以为你要让我亲，结果你没让我亲。然后我就想，等等，你要让我亲的。
And you just, I was too embarrassed. Hey, we, you guys, that was so good. Jason, I had to give you, I know I had to put a pill in your mouth. You had to put a pill in my mouth and I had to put a rest in my mouth. And I kept telling you that I hadn't washed my hands. But, but, this is about Kayleigh. I know, this is about Kayleigh. This is about Kayleigh.
结果你……我当时太尴尬了。嘿，我们……你们俩，刚才演得太好了。杰森，我得给你……我知道我得把一颗药塞进你嘴里。你得把一颗药塞进我嘴里，然后我得把一截东西塞进我嘴里。我一直告诉你我没洗手。但是……但是，这是关于凯莉的。我知道，这是关于凯莉的。这是关于凯莉的。
So, what did they put pads on? They put pads on. Can you please escort this guy out of the game? I know. This is, they put padding on and then you push on the pad? Yeah. No, huh? No, I didn't know that.
所以，他们垫了护垫吗？他们垫了护垫。能请这个人离场吗？我知道。这是……他们垫了护垫，然后你在护垫上按压？对。不对，哈？不，我不知道。
Yeah, and then they'll cut to, you know, his chest and they'll take the pad off. You know, you know, you know, you star wars, you know, they don't shoot that in space, right? Yeah. And the lightsabers are not, they won't really cut you in half. Hey, May the fourth be with you. Good.
是的，然后他们会切到……你知道的，他的胸部特写，然后把护垫拿掉。你知道的，你知道的……《星球大战》，你知道的，他们不是真的在太空中拍摄的，对吧？是的。而且光剑也不是……它们不会真的把你劈成两半。嘿，愿原力与你同在。好。
And we will be right back. Hey, May the fourth be with you. Good. And we will be right back. Spartanist listener, we get support from Zippercruder. Everybody's got some hidden talents. And, you know, mine is I can do the big loud whistle without using my fingers, so I kind of go like, shhh.
我们马上回来。嘿，愿原力与你同在。好。我们马上回来。Spartanist听众们，我们得到了ZipRecruiter的赞助。每个人都有一些隐藏的天赋。你知道的，我的天赋是不动用手指就能吹出又响又大的口哨，所以我的声音大概是这样的，嘘——
You know, not bad. That was done live in real time. Anyway, the point is this. From hard skills to soft skills, it takes all kinds of talent to make a business successful. And if you're hiring and you want to find the right combination of talent for your open roles, you need zippercrooter.
你知道的，还不错。那是实时现场表演的。总之，重点是这样的。从硬技能到软技能，让一家企业成功需要各种各样的人才。如果你正在招聘，并且想为你的空缺岗位找到合适的人才组合，你需要ZipRecruiter。
And right now, you can try it for free at zippercrooter.com-smartless. Zipper Cruder uses powerful technology to find and send you people who skills and experience match your job. If you see someone you're really interested in, Zipper Cruder lets you easily invite them to apply to your job, to increase your chances of getting them before your competition does. Tap into Zipper Cruder's unmatched talent for finding great candidates.
现在，你可以在ziprecruiter.com/smartless上免费试用。ZipRecruiter使用强大的技术来寻找并向你推荐那些技能和经验与你的职位匹配的人。如果你看到真正感兴趣的人，ZipRecruiter能让你轻松邀请他们申请你的职位，从而在竞争对手之前增加招揽他们的机会。利用ZipRecruiter在寻找优秀候选人方面无可匹敌的天赋。
Four out of five employers who post on Zipper Cruder get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zipper Cruder for free. Zipper Cruder.com slash smartless. Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash SMA RTL ESS. Zipper Cruder. The smartest way to hire. Smartless is supported by state farm. Insurance can be confusing sometimes.
在ZipRecruiter上发布招聘信息的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天就能找到高质量的候选人。自己去看看吧。访问这个专属网址，免费试用ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。再次强调，网址是ziprecruiter.com/SMA-RT-LESS。ZipRecruiter。最聪明的招聘方式。SmartLess受到State Farm的大力支持。保险有时可能会让人感到困惑。
That's why state farm is there for your what ifs because they know the rest of your life is already full of thinking about other things. Like, what if your life was a playlist? Imagine how crazy it would be. Your first song might be a noisy track called Kids. The second one, a spooky track called Home Ownership. Then like 100 more songs called Work, Health, Pets, Cars, Yardwork.
这就是为什么State Farm随时准备应对你的各种“如果”，因为他们知道你的余生已经充满了对其他事情的思考。比如，如果你的生活是一个播放列表？想象一下那会有多疯狂。你的第一首歌曲可能是一首名为《孩子们》的吵闹曲目。第二首，是一首名为《拥有房产》的诡异曲目。然后大约还有100首名为《工作》、《健康》、《宠物》、《汽车》、《庭院劳动》的歌曲。
The playlist goes on, and once you put it on repeat and add shuffle mode, things might not sound all that jazzy. That's why the last track you'd want to add to your life's playlist is called Insurance Uncertainties, with lyrics like, what if I'd like to add coverage to my policy? What if I have a question at 3 a.m.? Well, there are some positive notes that can help you keep your life in harmony. You can file a claim on the State Farm mobile app, talk to a real person, including your agent, and you can call day or night about insurance coverage and policy questions, because that's just what they do.
播放列表还在继续，一旦你把它设为循环播放并加上随机模式，事情听起来可能就不会那么美妙了。这就是为什么你最不想加入生活播放列表的最后一首曲目叫做《保险不确定性》，里面有这样的歌词：如果我想在保单中增加保障会怎样？如果我在凌晨3点有问题怎么办？好吧，有一些积极的音符可以帮助你的生活保持和谐。你可以在State Farm移动应用程序上提交理赔申请，与真人交谈，包括你的代理人，并且你可以不分昼夜地就保险范围和保单问题打电话，因为这正是他们所做的。
So no matter how noisy your life may get, insurance can still be music to your ears. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. Call or go to statefarm.com for a quote today. SmartLess is supported by rocket money. OK. I have a bunch of subscriptions over the years that I've accumulated. And I realized recently that some that I thought I didn't have anymore were still ongoing. And embarrassingly enough, I was still paying for them.
所以，无论你的生活变得多么喧嚣，保险依然可以为你奏出美妙的音乐。就像一个好邻居，State Farm一直都在。今天就打电话或访问statefarm.com获取报价吧。SmartLess受到Rocket Money的支持。好的。这些年来我积累了一堆订阅服务。我最近才意识到，有些我以为已经取消了的服务其实还在继续。尴尬的是，我居然还在为它们付钱。
Do you know how much your subscriptions really cost? Most Americans think they spend around 80 bucks a month on subscriptions. But the actual total is closer to $200 a month. If you don't know exactly how much you're spending every month, you need rocket money. Rocket money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions, monitors your spending, and helps you lower your bills all in one place. Rocket money will quickly and easily find your subscriptions for you and for any you don't want to pay for anymore,
你知道你的订阅服务实际花费了多少吗？大多数美国人认为他们每月在订阅上花大约80美元。但实际总额接近每月200美元。如果你不确切知道自己每个月花了多少钱，你需要Rocket Money。Rocket Money是一款个人理财应用程序，它可以在一个地方帮你查找并取消不需要的订阅、监控你的支出并帮你降低账单。Rocket Money会快速轻松地为你找出订阅服务，对于任何你不想再付费的订阅，
just hit cancel and Rocket money will cancel it for you. It's that easy. Rocket money also helps you manage all your finances in one place and automatically categorize your expenses. So you can easily track your budget in real time and also get alerted if anything looks off. Over 3 million people have used rocket money, saving the average person up to $720 a year.
只需点击取消，Rocket Money就会为你取消。就是这么简单。Rocket Money还能帮你在一处管理所有财务，并自动对你的支出进行分类。这样你就可以轻松实时追踪预算，如果发现任何异常还会收到提醒。超过300万人在使用Rocket Money，平均每年帮每人节省高达720美元。
So stop throwing your money away. Cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage your expenses the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless rocketmoney.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. Kayleigh, were you prepared for the uber success of Big Bang like all the fame, the notoriety, the money, everything changed and sort of exponentially every year.
所以，别再把钱白白扔掉了。通过访问rocketmoney.com/smartless，以简单的方式取消不需要的订阅并管理你的支出。网址是rocketmoney.com/smartless，即rocketmoney.com/smartless。现在让我们回到节目中。凯莉，你对《生活大爆炸》取得的巨大成功做好准备了吗？比如所有的名气、声誉、金钱，一切都发生了变化，并且每年都在呈指数级增长。
Noterite means something bad. Noterite means a big thing. Should be super pilot like a couple times or something. Yes, I was actually the third actress to join Big Bang Theory. Really? Yes. Wow. They did a pie, they did, I believe, two pie.
声誉（Notoriety）意味着不好的事情。声誉（Notoriety）意味着一件大事。应该像试播集那样拍个好几次什么的。是的，我其实是第三个加入《生活大爆炸》的演员。真的吗？是的。哇。他们拍了一个试播集，他们拍了，我相信是两个试播集。
Old truck had the thinning shears out, huh? 100% yeah. Yeah, yeah. You know who did it? Do you know the people you don't have to say their names, but do you know the people who did it before you, the pilot? I knew one of them. Yeah, I knew one of them.
老卡车把打薄剪拿出来了，是吧？100%是的。是的，是的。你知道是谁演的吗？你知道那些人是谁吗？你不用说出他们的名字，但你知道在你之前拍试播集的那些人吗？我认识其中一个。是的，我认识其中一个。
Awkward, uh, weird. Well, yeah, well, I knew her later. So it was like, it wasn't like she was my friend at the time I'm like, oh, you got a show and then I went and took it But no, I did know her later and she actually ended up guest-arring that she was still friends with everybody was all fine Oh, good. I know so they shot One pilot trashed it to second pilot trashed it and then the third pilot you were in the pilot Yes, they kept rewriting it and revamping it.
尴尬，呃，诡异。好吧，是的，嗯，我后来认识了她。所以就好像……当时她还不是我的朋友，我心想，哦，你接了一部剧，然后我去接手了。不过不，我后来确实认识了她，她甚至还去客串过，她和所有人都还是朋友，一切都挺好的。哦，太好了。我知道，所以他们拍了……第一个试播集被废了，第二个试播集被废了，然后第三个试播集里有你。是的，他们一直在重写和翻新。
I mean, it was totally changed when I joined. Like, it wasn't what it was at all. And so what is it about, like, this is fascinating to me, what is it about that particular show that they kept throwing money at it and redoing it? And what was it that they believed in so much just the concept or, and the actors in it or like, where as opposed to other
我的意思是，我加入时完全变了样。它根本不是原来的样子了。所以关于……这对我来说太迷人了，那部特别的节目究竟有什么魔力，以至于他们不断地往里砸钱并重新制作？究竟是什么让他们如此坚信不疑——仅仅是概念、里面的演员，还是说，与其他
shows you should have pilot didn't go they throw it out. Like by right. I think I remember Chuck did a cup. I know he's talked about this before, but he just like really believed in it and the studio believed in Chuck and he kept saying give us another chance give us another chance like I can make I think I'm going to make this work. And you know he's Chuck and he does. So they single hennaley kept sitcoms alive for less.
没能通过试播集就被扔掉的节目相比……没错。我想我记得查克（Chuck）做过几次……我知道他以前谈论过这个，但他就是真的坚信不疑，而且电视台也相信查克，他一直说：“再给我们一次机会，再给我们一次机会……我觉得我能把它做好。”你知道的，他可是查克，他也确实做到了。所以他凭一己之力让情景喜剧得以延续。
100% yeah. But he kept saying, I'm gonna get this right, I'm gonna get this right.. You know what's so crazy? I feel like my sort of, I hated him in this word, whatever, this fame or whatever. I was such on a slow uphill climb. I feel like there are actors who gets,
比如他们可能拍了……我不知道，他们拍了一部大制作电影什么的，突然之间一夜成名，然后他们会想：哦，天哪。我真的不觉得我的情况是那样的。就像我……我从五岁起就开始干这个了。倒不是说我那时候有多出名，但我一直在这个行业里，
like maybe they do, I don't know, they do some huge film or something that all of a sudden write it overnight fame and they're like, oh my God. I don't really feel like it was like that for me. Like I've kind of, I've been doing this since I was five years old. Not that I was famous back then, but I've always been in the business
而且我一直都在做无数的事情。这从未对产生过影响，我也从未体验过那种“哦，天哪”的时刻。我在《生活大爆炸》时期就知道……因为那是你谋生的手段。是的，但《生活大爆炸》每周有大约3000万观众，这简直太疯狂了。我知道，我们工作……《生活大爆炸》每周有大约3000万观众。我知道。这太疯狂了。
and I've always done a million things. And it never affected me that I never felt that moment of, oh my God. I knew in Big Bang's day. Because it was what you did for a living. Yeah, but Big Bang Theory haven't got like 30 million viewers a week, like it was insane. I know, we worked Bang Theory haven't got like 30 million viewers a week. I know. It was insane.
我知道。我的意思是，那太棒了。我们欣喜若狂。肖恩和我……当我们拍那部剧时，《米勒一家》和《特种部队》，我们是在你们后面播出。哦，天哪。在《生活大爆炸》后面播了一年。是的。
I know. I mean, it was awesome. We were thrilled. Sean and I did when we did that show, The Millers and Special Forces and we were on behind you guys. Oh, me. Behind Big Bang Theory for a year. Yeah.
而你们凭一己之力让我们留在了荧屏上，因为我们有《生活大爆炸》做领跑剧。我们当时想：太棒了。如果我们愿意，哪怕播一整集拨号音都可以。但随之而来的落差也会很大，对吧？然后你就有了保持那个收视数字的压力。我们的收视率确实大幅下降了。是的，然后他们……然后他们把我们调档了，接着我们就想：哦，我们完蛋了。但这确实是一个小小的轰动现象，伙计。
And you single-handedly like kept us on the air because we had the lead in a Big Bang Theory. We're like, sweet. We could have just air some dial tone if we wanted. But then you can't drop off a lot, right? Then you got the pressure of trying to hold that number. We did drop off. Yeah, then they got, then they moved us and then we were like, oh, we're screwed. But it was a little phenomenon, man.
我不知道。就像……它太庞大了。而且我知道，我知道几个……我确实认识几个人，但我绝对认识约翰尼（Johnny）一点点，他真的是个很好的人。当然，哦，他太棒了。我太喜欢他了。他真的是个很好的人。他有着非常美好的灵魂。他就像是在过自己的生活。是的，真的搬家了……搬去田纳西州了。是的，那太棒了。他很好。我得告诉他我看到你并和你谈过了。是的，请代我向他问好。
I don't know. Like, she's just massive. And I know, you know who I know. I know a few people, but I certainly know Johnny a little bit such a nice Of course, oh, he's great. I love him. He's such a nice guy. He's such a nice soul He's like doing his thing. Yeah, really moved to do move to like Tennessee Yeah, that's so great. He's good. I gotta tell him I saw you got talked to you. Yeah, please say hi to inform me
好的，所以现在你做的事情是，你在某种程度上将你对表演的热情和对网球的热情结合了起来，尽管你让克里斯·梅西纳（Chris Messina）去负责网球部分，但给我们讲讲这部由阿格里特（Agriette）制品的、名为《好戏登场》（Based on a True Story）的精彩新剧吧。你知道吗，你可能知道这一点，但当我遇到汤姆·佩尔弗里先生时，
All right, so now what you've done is you've somewhat combined your passion for acting and your passion for tennis, although you're letting Chris Messina do the tennis part, but tell us about this incredible new show called based on a true story produced by Agriette. Do you know that you probably know this, but when I met Mr. Tom Palfrey,
他手里拿着这个剧本。我们在约会大约三周的时候，他就已经在读这个了。我问：“你在看什么？”他说：“我在看这个《好戏登场》。”他说：“我演不了，因为我有别的剧要拍。”我确实知道那件事。是的。然后我读了它。
he had this script in his hand. He was reading it like three weeks into dating him. And I go, what do you read? And he goes, I'm reading this based on a true story. I can't do it because I've got some other show. I did know that. Yes. And I read it.
当时我就想：把那个给我。让我读读。他说：“这太搞笑了。”这显然是一年前的事了。是的，是的。然后我说：“哦，天哪，这太爆笑了。”他……
And I was like, give me that. Let me read it. He goes, it's so funny. This is obviously a year ago. Yeah, yeah. And I go, oh my God, this is hilarious. He. He goes, it's so funny. This is obviously a year ago. Yeah, yeah. And I go, oh my god, this is hilarious. He goes, I know it's so funny. It's Jason's doing it and all this stuff is just hilarious.
他说：“我知道这太搞笑了。杰森在演，而且里面所有这些东西都太搞笑了。”我还住在杰森的房车里呢。我不能……是的。我不能。他永远不会去读它的。他永远没空去读它。好吧，他的意思是：你要去演那个水管工。他本来可能是要去演那个水管工的。在《黑钱胜地》与他合作之后，我听到或想到关于……
I still live from Jason's trailer. I can't, yeah. I can't. He'll never read it. He'll never get around to reading it. Well, he was like, you're going to play the plumber. He was going to maybe play in the plumber. After working with him on Ozark, anything and everything I heard about or thought about
你知道的，人们开始跟我谈论他。就像是：“嘿，让汤姆来演这个怎么样？让汤姆来演那个怎么样？”他太喜欢这个了，伙计。很有可能，这可能是我知道的事情之一，但这是众多项目中的一个，他手头可能有一堆东西。但不是很疯狂吗？当时我就想：这太有趣了。我读了下去。
you know, and people were talking to me about him. It's like, yeah, what about Tom for this? What about Tom for this? He loves it so much, man. Chances are high that maybe that was something I was aware of, but it was one of many, he probably had a bunch of stuff. But is that crazy that I was like, that's funny. And I went through it.
我说：这太绝了。显然，那甚至是在我接到这个角色的试镜电话几个月前。而且最初剧本写得很不一样。那对夫妇有更大的孩子。故事也稍微有些不同。所以当我接到电话，并且开始和你们讨论这件事时，我当时就想：我太喜欢这个了。但我不知道我能不能演有十几岁孩子的母亲。
I said, this is brilliant. Obviously, that was months before I even ever got the call for it. And things were written very differently. The couple had older kids. The story was a little bit different. So once I got the call and I was kind of talking about it with you guys, I was like, I love this so much. But I don't know if I would have teenagers.
我说，这太棒了。显然，那是在我接到电话的几个月前，而且剧本的设定完全不同。那对夫妇有更大的孩子。故事也有些许不同。所以当我接到电话，和你们讨论这件事时，我就想，我太喜欢了。但我不知道我是否能应付十几岁的孩子。
Like we started talking and then Craig or showrunner was like, we'll take away the kids. Like they were kind of helping me figure out how this could be. I loved it so much. Plus I loved your crime. I loved tennis. I loved working in LA. I was like, I need all these things.
就像我们开始聊天，然后我们的制片人克雷格就说，我们把孩子拿掉吧。就像他们有点在帮我弄清楚这会是怎样的。我太喜欢了。另外我喜欢你的罪案。我喜欢网球。我喜欢在洛杉矶工作。我就觉得，我需要所有这些。
This is great. So the general concept is that you and Christmasena are married. The great, the great Christmasena. The best. We'll hold for a pause there. The best, the great Chris Messina. The best. We'll hold for a pause there. The best. He plays an X-Tenist star. You play a realtor that is obsessed with True Crime podcast.
这太棒了。所以总体概念是你和克里斯·梅西纳结婚了。伟大的，伟大的克里斯·梅西纳。最棒的。我们在那儿停顿一下。最棒的，伟大的克里斯·梅西纳。最棒的。我们在那儿停顿一下。最棒的。他扮演一个前网球明星。你扮演一个痴迷于真实罪案播客的房地产经纪人。
You have a plumber come to the house to fix a toilet played by ironically Tom Bateman. Yes, fabulous. Isn't that weird? Yes. And this guy turns out to maybe be a serial killer, and you guys decide, well, we're not going to turn him in if he agrees to do a podcast with us about his serial killer. I got to see him. And we'll keep his name away from the authorities.
你找了个水管工来家里修马桶，讽刺的是由汤姆·巴特曼扮演。是的，太棒了。这不是很奇怪吗？是的。而这家伙结果可能是一个连环杀手，你们决定，好吧，如果他同意和我们一起做一个关于他的连环杀手的播客，我们就不把他交出去。我得去见见他。而且我们会对当局隐瞒他的名字。
No more silly. That's great. There's probably a better way to describe it, but that's the bones of it, right? That sounds great. Wait, when is this on? This is coming. June 8th. June 8th on the peacock. Absolutely. What, this is streaming on the cock?
别再犯傻了。太棒了。可能有一种更好的描述方式，但这大致就是核心，对吧？听起来很棒。等等，这个什么时候播？这是要来了。6月8日。6月8日在Peacock上线。绝对的。什么，这个是在Peacock上播吗？
It's streaming out of the cock. Of course. Yep, yep, yep. Wow. That's what we always say on anything for. Wait, but that sounds really great. I know, it does sound really, really good. It was such a quirky. It was so insane the story. I thought it was so brilliant. I said, I have to be part of this. And then like, after we had signed on, we got everything going.
它在Peacock上播流媒体。当然。是的，是的，是的。哇。我们在任何地方都这么说。等等，但这听起来真的很好。我知道，听起来确实非常、非常棒。这是一个如此古怪的故事。这个故事太疯狂了。我觉得太绝了。我说，我必须成为其中的一部分。然后呢，在我们签约后，一切都开始运转了。
I came to LA to do some chemistry reads. And Jason wasn't there, but the producers were there. And I was talking to everyone. And I sat them down and like, guys, because they had written it and it was done and ready to go. I was like, guys, what if this character was pregnant? Just a bit more. I was like, what if this character was pregnant?
我来到洛杉矶做一些化学反应试读。杰森不在那儿，但制片人在。我和每个人都在聊天。我让他们坐下，就像，伙计们，因为他们已经写好了，而且已经完成了，准备好了。我就说，伙计们，如果这个角色怀孕了会怎么样？再多一点。我就说，如果这个角色怀孕了会怎么样？
Just a bit false. Just a bit false. I'm like, now think, think. I'll answer first. Yeah, really think heart, cause this could really be in there. Like, well, I'm like, no, really? And they're looking me and they're like,
就差一点。就差一点。我就想，现在想想，想想。我先回答。是的，真的要用心想，因为这真的可以写进去。就像，嗯，我说，不，真的吗？他们看着我，就像，
what, I'm like, surprise. Oh my God. Oh my God, we were like a month out from shooting, maybe a little longer, but I said, do you think you could write it in? And how many months were you? When we started shooting, I was five months. I mean, we shot three weeks before I gave birth.
什么，我说，惊喜。天哪。天哪，我们离拍摄大约有一个月了，也许稍微长一点，但我说，你们觉得能把它写进去吗？你当时几个月了？我们开始拍摄时我五个月。我的意思是，我在生孩子前三周还在拍。
Yeah. About up until three weeks before I gave birth. Yeah, so I was five months when we started. So let's say I was like four. Oh my God. And didn't they say, well, well, Kayleigh, we can delay started production. Like have your kid enjoy and you were like, no, no, no, no, no,
对。一直拍到我生孩子前三周。是的，所以开始时我五个月。所以可以说是四个月左右。天哪。他们难道没有说，嗯，凯莉，我们可以推迟制作。就像让你的孩子享受生活，然后你说，不，不，不，不，不，
I want, right? No, I want to do it now because I also, not only did I want to do the show and I was so ready to do it, I actually not be, and also I wanted to, for them to write in the pregnancy, I actually thought it worked for the show. And once we all talked it out, it actually were, I don't remember it not being about this couple being pregnant.
我想要，对吧？不，我现在就要拍，因为我也，不仅是因为我想拍这部剧，而且我太准备好了，我其实不想，而且我也希望他们把怀孕写进去，我其实觉得这对剧集很合适。一旦我们大家都商量好了，其实它就——我不记得没有关于这对夫妇怀孕情节的时候了。
Plus the way they wrote it in was so brilliant. Like it never focused on the pregnancy. It just was, I was just pregnant. Also, it's the jeopardy too, that you're basically working with the serial killer and you can see this big, huge baby box the whole way through. Yeah, fully pregnant.
再加上他们写进去的方式太巧妙了。就像它从不把重点放在怀孕上。它只是，我只是怀孕了。还有那种危险，就是你基本上是在和一个连环杀手合作，而你从头到尾都能看到这个巨大的孕肚。对，完全怀孕了。
That's cool. You were five months pregnant and through till what being eight months pregnant by the time we wrapped? Four weeks before I gave birth, it was my birthday. Yeah, but it was awesome because I got to, I mean, what job I got to eat what I wanted.
这太酷了。你怀孕五个月，一直到我们杀青时怀孕几个月？在我生孩子前四周，那是我的生日。是的，但这太棒了，因为我能够，我的意思是，有什么工作能让我吃我想吃的东西。
I was treated like a frickin' queen. I was the best. I wore what I wanted. I was felt very empowered. And also like, I think this is just so long. Yes, comfy shoes. I've been able to like play my eight.
我被当成女王一样对待。这真是太棒了。我穿我想穿的衣服。我感到非常有力量。还有就是，我觉得这太长了。是的，舒服的鞋子。我能够扮演我的—
I've been in this business for so long that I thought it was cool. Like, okay, now people are seeing me like I'm gonna be real about this. And I'm gonna show that this is exactly what I am. And I'm pregnant and it's fine. And I'm working. And I thought it was like a good thing to do.
我在这一行待了这么久，我觉得这很酷。就像，好吧，现在人们看到我了，我得对这件事保持真实。我要展现出这就是真实的我。我怀孕了，这很好。我在工作。我觉得这是一件好事。
I don't know, It just felt right. Yeah. I would have killed to play that killer. I want to play. I know he's great. He's really great. Oh my God. He is great. I can't wait to see it. They're all great.
不知道，这感觉就是对的。是的。我愿意拼死演那个杀手。我想演。我知道他很棒。他真的很棒。天哪。他真的很棒。我迫不及待想看了。他们都很棒。
It's really cool, weird show and very funny. Now you're very lucky because it's shot in Los Angeles. You're going to be able to bring Matilda to the set if and when there's a second season. Yes. I've he thought about like how that's all going to kind of play out. I mean, dude, I would a great thing to bring Matilda to the set if and when there's a second season, yes. I've been thought about like how that's all gonna kind of play out. Dude, I would do a second season in a heartbeat. Let's get it done.
这是一部非常酷、很怪异的剧，而且非常搞笑。现在你真的很幸运，因为它是在洛杉矶拍摄的。如果有第二季的话，你将能够把玛蒂尔达带到片场。是的。我考虑过这一切将如何发展。我是说，伙计，如果有第二季的话，把玛蒂尔达带到片场将是一件多么棒的事，是的。我一直在考虑这一切将如何发展。伙计，我毫不犹豫就会拍第二季。把它搞定吧。
Let's get this done today. He was one of the most fun experiences I have ever, I really mean that. And that Christmas scene is just a real joy. We laughed. And that's what's fun, not to, we move on after this. But that is real, I mean, the writing is fantastic, concepts fun and all that stuff,
今天就把这事办了。这是我有过最有趣的经历之一，我真的是这么说的。而且克里斯·梅西纳真的带来了很多快乐。我们笑了。这就是有趣的地方，不是说，我们之后再继续。但那是真的，我是说，剧本太棒了，概念很有趣诸如此类的，
but the chemistry between you two guys, I don't know, it's just, I do stuff some time when people say, hey boy, how does you guys get such great chemistry? Well, when you have two really nice people, it's pretty simple. Thank you. Chris, Sean Will, don't you guys agree?
但你们俩之间的化学反应，我不知道，有时候当人们说，嘿，小伙子，你们俩怎么能有这么好的化学反应？嗯，当你有两个真正好的人时，这就很简单了。谢谢。克里斯、肖恩、威尔，你们不这么认为吗？
Like, chemistry's not a mystery if you're not working with a dickhead. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Chris, Sean Will, don't you guys agree? Like, the campus is not a mystery if you're not working with a dickhead. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly. Chris, just awesome. People are like, well, they had great chemistry. Yeah, because they're normal, nice people. Yeah, exactly.
就像，如果你不是和一个混蛋合作，化学反应就不是什么谜团。是的，是的，完全正确。克里斯、肖恩、威尔，你们不这么认为吗？就像，如果你不是和一个混蛋合作，化学反应就不是什么谜团。是的，是的，是的。完全正确。克里斯，简直太棒了。人们会说，哦，他们有很好的化学反应。是的，因为他们是正常、善良的人。是的，完全正确。
Yeah, it's good. And it's infectious and it works for the characters too because you guys are kind of aweshocksing while working with a serial killer. It's pretty great. No, we had a blast, man. It was awesome. I can't even tell you.
是的，这很好。而且很有感染力，对角色也很有效，因为你们在和连环杀手合作时有点大惊小怪的。这真是太棒了。不，我们玩得很开心，伙计。这太棒了。我甚至无法形容。
All right. So, about why I just want to say it out loud. It's what's it called again based on a true story, true story, junate streaming on the cock, just so we can say it, just so I can, because neither of you can say it, but I can say it, you know, I can feel it. I can feel it.
好吧。所以，关于为什么我只想大声说出来。它叫什么来着，基于真实故事，真实故事，6月8日在Peacock上线，这样我们就可以说出来，这样我就可以，因为你们俩都不能说，但我可以说，你知道，我能感觉到。我能感觉到。
Set his calendar. You're ready to do it. We have a viewing part. You're gonna do a viewing. We're doing it. Are you kidding? Are you fucking doing it? What do you, I want to know, I have something. Go ahead, Sean.
定好日历。你准备好了。我们办个观影派对。你要办观影会吗？我们正在办。你在开玩笑吗？你他妈的在办吗？你，我想知道，我有件事。说吧，肖恩。
Do you have like, do you have any kind of desire to write and to be a writer and to write scripts and like, direct or a little bit? I think I could direct. I think I would be a good director because I like to get in and get out. I don't waste a lot of time. I'm also not every, it was funny working with Macino
你有没有，你有任何想要写作、成为一名作家、写剧本以及导演之类的渴望吗？我觉得我可以导演。我觉得我会是一个好导演，因为我喜欢切入重点，速战速决。我不会浪费太多时间。我也不像每个人，和梅西纳合作很有意思，
who is very likes to prepare and likes to rehearse and watch every playback. I, that is not my jam at all. You're in your arm. Yeah, I like to get in there. Why are we talking about this? Let's just shoot it. And then Chris is like, but we have to,
他非常喜欢做准备，喜欢排练，喜欢看每一次回放。我，那完全不是我的风格。你在开玩笑。是的，我喜欢直接开干。我们为什么要讨论这个？直接拍吧。然后克里斯就说，但是我们必须，
what are we going to do now? Like he's hysterical. So the two of us together kind of balance those like me with Laura Lenny. Laura was very, very prepared, very sort of always the notes in the squad and the lines always learned. And like it was very admirable. But I just my brain doesn't work.
我们现在该怎么办？就像他歇斯底里一样。所以我们俩在一起有点平衡了那些——就像我和劳拉·琳妮一起。劳拉非常、非常准备充分，总是记笔记，台词也总是背熟了。而且这非常令人钦佩。但我的大脑就是不听使唤。
Me too. A very admirable. I mean, my brain is not working that way either. It's just not for me. I know, but it makes a great partnership. I'm not a playback watcher. As an actor, I can't watch playback. So Tracy, what happens here is that you shoot a scene and then you can go to the monitor,
我也是。非常令人钦佩。我的意思是，我的大脑也不是那样运作的。这不适合我。我知道，但这造就了伟大的合作关系。我不是一个看回放的人。作为一个演员，我无法看回放。所以特雷西，这里发生的事情是你拍完一个场景，然后你可以去监视器，
a little TV next to where you just shot and they'll play it back for you so you can see what you did good, what you did bad, what the technical things are, you need to look out for. Then you go and you shoot it again. And it really was initially, not for the actress, it's for you generally for the director. So the director can watch maybe the producer. See the camera scene. Yeah, see what the camera scene and say,
就是你刚拍摄的地方旁边的一台小电视，他们会为你回放，这样你就能看到你哪里演得好，哪里演得不好，有哪些技术问题需要注意。然后你再去拍一遍。这实际上最初，不是给演员看的，通常是给导演看的。所以导演可以看，也许还有制片人。看镜头画面。是的，看看镜头画面并说，
be like, hey, let's get that again. Maybe there's a bump on the camera move. Maybe the light wasn't right. Maybe the wrong line, whatever. By the way, you know who invented or created the playback? Who's that show? Jerry Lewis. Is that right?
就像，嘿，我们再拍一次。摄像机移动时可能有个颠簸。灯光可能不对。台词可能错了，诸如此类的。顺便说一句，你知道是谁发明或创造了回放功能吗？是谁？杰瑞·刘易斯。是这样吗？
Really? Huh, yeah. Now some actors will not look at playback. And they won't even see the film once it's all done, cut together, and I don't get that. I learned so much about what I did wrong by looking at what I do. Like watching the end product.
真的吗？啊，是的。现在有些演员不看回放。他们甚至在电影全部完成、剪辑好之后都不看，我不理解这一点。通过观察我所做的事情，我学到了很多关于我做错了什么。就像看最终产品。
Yeah, it's like shoot it and go home and then go to the next job. And it's me too. Otherwise, you just obsess. You obsess about like, what about, you know, I can't do it. I'm the same way. Maybe I should do that with golf. Well, maybe I should care a little bit less. Well, let me just tell you, I was going to say to you, I talked about you at great length
是的，就像拍完就回家，然后去下一个工作。我也是。否则，你只会纠结。你会纠结于，比如，怎么样，你知道，我做不到。我也是这样。也许我应该把这用在打高尔夫上。好吧，也许我应该少在乎一点。好吧，我来告诉你，我要对你说，我昨天和乔什详谈了关于你的事。
with Josh last night. Oh, boy. This is true. And I did bring him that you're not, you know, Josh. Oh, Josh. Yeah, it's a This is true. And I did bring him that you're not, you know, Josh. Oh, Josh. Yes, I'm a friend of ours and we play golf. Golf or jump. And so Josh, he's a, Kale, he's a friend of ours.
哦，天哪。这是真的。我确实向他提起你不是，你知道的，乔什。哦，乔什。是的，这是一个——这是真的。我确实向他提起你不是，你知道的，乔什。哦，乔什。是的，他是我们的朋友，我们一起打高尔夫。高尔夫或跳跃。所以乔什，他是个，凯莉，他是我们的朋友。
He's a ball, he's a ball fellow. And I keep saying that I want him to start wearing a different wig every day. And I can't even be amazing. Because he keeps his head shaved. And I'm like, if he showed up every day with a different wig, oh my God, I never, that is so fun. So anyway, we were saying, apart from
他是个球类爱好者，他是个球类爱好者。我一直在说我想让他每天戴一顶不同的假发。这难道不令人惊叹吗？因为他把头剃光了。我就想，如果他每天都带着一顶不同的假发出现，天哪，我从来没有，那太有趣了。无论如何，我们说，除了
the fact that Jason, I think you're malnourished and your blood sugar is abnormally low and that that's what makes you cranky all the time in everything you do, not just golf. I think on on top of that, you need to stand over the ball and hit it. Right. You have too many thoughts. And Jason is known as one of the slower golfers in the Los Angeles. I was slow yesterday. I was slow yesterday. And he thinks about way too much. And and Kale, you know, as a actual, you know, competitive
除了杰森，我觉得你营养不良，你的血糖异常低，这就是让你在做的每件事上都变得暴躁的原因，不仅仅是高尔夫。我觉得除此之外，你需要站在球上方然后击打它。对。你有太多想法了。而杰森被称为洛杉矶打高尔夫最慢的人之一。我昨天打得很慢。我昨天打得很慢。而且他想得太多了。而且，凯莉，你知道，作为一个真正的、你知道的，竞技运动员，有时你只需要顺其自然。你得走。你得走。你得走。是的。也许，也许凯莉需要成为那个来跟你一起打球、陪你散步并成为你的某种运动心理学家的人。是的，做我的低语者。我对高尔夫一窍不通，这项运动会把我逼疯的。就像，它会把我逼疯的。
athlete, that sometimes you just have to let it. You're going to go. You gotta go. You gotta go. Yeah. Maybe, maybe Kale needs to be the person to come play with you and walk with you and be your kind of sports psychologist. Yeah, be my whisper. I would be so bad at golf, that sport would make me insane. Like, it would make me insane.
但你可以开导他，你可以说，杰伊，快点，击球，击球，击球。保龄球怎么样？你们喜欢打保龄球吗？好了，凯莉，这太棒了。是的，谢谢你今天加入我们。抱歉，不幸的是，有人决定把整件事弄砸了。我们聊了一些关于保龄球的废话。
But you could talk him through, you could be like, Jay, speed it up, hit it, hit the ball and hit the ball. What about bowling? Do you guys like to bowl? All right, Kayleigh, this has been great. Yeah, thank you for joining us today. Sorry, unfortunately, somebody decided to capsize the whole thing. We saw a bullshit about bowling.
那是托尼奖提名的演员。好吧，你说乔什是个球类爱好者，而我是个球类爱好者。然后你就聊到了保龄球。安托瓦内特·佩里刚刚气得活过来了。凯莉，我爱你。谢谢你们。你们太棒了。
That's a Tony award-nominated actor. Well, you said Josh is a ball guy, and I'm a ball guy. And then you went to bowling. And I liked to bowl. Antoinette Perry just rolled over and. Kaley, I love you. Thank you guys. You crushed this.
你们太棒了。这太棒了。你这个女孩真会聊天。如果我是个女孩，就在头发上扎个像你一样的发圈。你觉得这个发圈怎么样？我总是这样。这是我的招牌。我总是用发圈，因为老派的我总是会说，听着，伙计们，事情是这样的，我觉得，我觉得我们需要，
You crushed this. Thank you. This was so great. You got real good chat on your girl. If I was a girl, where is scrunchy in my hair like you do? What do you think of the scrunchy? I always do. This is my bit. I always do with scrunch because old school I always go like, listen guys, the thing is, that I think that I think that what we need to,
我总是用我的发圈。我一直都这样。我总是把发圈放在那儿。我太喜欢了。我从没看清过发圈。我看了大概20年了。是的，我就像，伙计们，我觉得问题是，看，如果我们去那边，
I always do my scrunchies. I do it this whole time. I always do my scrunchies there. I love that. I never see the scrunchies very well. I've seen it a bit for under 20 years. Yeah, I was like, guys, I think the problem is, look, if we go over there,
我们可以，我看那个发圈，我觉得问题是看如果我们去那边 可以，我看到一个电话，他正把头发聚拢，把一个假的塑料发圈戴在头上 是的，这是我的最爱，我太喜欢了。我有一个80年代的大发圈。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。超级可爱，伙计们太棒了。谢谢 好的，谢谢。你们太棒了。谢谢。度过愉快的一天，凯莉，谢谢。太有趣了。度过愉快的一天。再见，伙计们。再见，凯莉。谢谢。再见。再见。拜拜，拜拜。再见。
can we, and I see the scrunchies, I think the problem is look if we go over there Can we and I see a phone he's gathering his hair and putting a photo fake scrunchy in his hair Yeah, it's my favorite I love it. I have a big 80's scrunchy. I love it. I love it. Super cute guys are awesome. Thank you All right, thank you. Thank you guys are amazing. Thank you. So have a great rest of the day Kaley thank you. So fun. Have a great rest of the day. Bye, guys. Bye, Kayleigh. Thank you. Bye. Bye. Bye, bye, bye. Bye.
伙计们，那就是，她真的是个很有灵气的人。你知道，她身上有一种很棒的氛围。她说阳光包裹在皮肤里，但也许是灵魂包裹在皮肤里，对吧？还有一些阳光。她也是那种表现出非凡演技的个性，
You guys, that's just, she's just, that's a real spirit. You know, she got great vibe on. She said sunshine wrapped in skin, but maybe it's spirit wrapped in skin, huh? And some sunshine. She's one of those personalities, too, that's like a phenomenal actress,
但你能看出她是一个有趣的人，而且不像对待严肃工作那样把生活看得太严肃。凯莉就是，你知道的，我问过。充满活力的库柯。抱歉。她的名字应该叫充满活力的库柯。加冰。
but you can tell is a fun person and doesn't take life serious, like she does her work serious too. Kaylee was, you know, I've asked that. Bubbly Quoco. Sorry. Her name should be Bubbly Quoco. On ice.
充满活力的库柯。但是凯莉，她太棒了。她在《生活大爆炸》里表现得太棒了，而且那么幽默有趣。是的，简直就像——就像一个极好的人。是的，她身上有那么多生命力。然后你会想，好吧，也许那就是她扮演的角色。不。
Bubbly Quoco. But Kaylee, but she's so great. She was so great on Big Bang theory and so funny and fun. Yeah, just like just like a little great. Yeah, she's had so much life to her. And then you think like, well, maybe that's sort of the character is playing. Nope.
她就是那样的人。她能量满满，太棒了。是的，随时随地。是的，你马上就想和她一起出去玩。你知道，顺便说一句，你有没有过这样的经历，当你下飞机时，当你要离开时，空乘人员，或者她过来？是这样的，是这样的，但请继续。
She is that person. She has great energy, great. Yeah, all the time. Yeah, you want to hang out with her immediately. You know, by the way, have you ever exited a plane when the flight attendant, when you're leaving and the flight attendant, or to her over? It is, it is, but go ahead.
是的，请继续。他说。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐，亲爱的威利。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐，亲爱的威利，祝你生日快乐 你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你，你， you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you want, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you want.
Yeah, go ahead. He says. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday sweet sweet willy-our-ninn. Happy birthday. Sweet, sweet, willy-earned, and happy birthday Sweet, sweet, willy-earned, and happy birthday You, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, So cute. That's a good one. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
是的，请便。他说。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐，亲爱的威利。祝你生日快乐。亲爱的威利，祝你生日快乐。亲爱的威利，祝你生日快乐。你，你，你……（重复省略）。太可爱了。这个真不错。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Unmbjerf. Smart, less. and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。《SmartLess》由 Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob Unmbjerf 100% 有机手工制作。在 Apple Podcasts 或 Wondry App 上订阅 Wondry Plus，即可享受聪明、精简且无广告的体验。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。